peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à 12h09 endroit bienvenue sur le blog
sur de tout le monde en parle
l'émission qui parle je sais pas il ya
un problème quoi l'émission qui parle
[Musique]
pourquoi mais pas l'émission de la
semaine dernière c'est bien ami de
l'homme en noir
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle l'émission qui parle
bah voilà avec nous ce soir pascal
sevran est à l'abri
il n'a pas eu ces postes nouvelle
révélation sur le 11 septembre
nouvelle relation sur la fuite du mollah
omar
son histoire d'amour et elvin ans
joe cocker pop
tous les militaires
le patron de charlie hebdo
david guetta et l'équipe des guignols
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
allez mes clients la grenouille alors je
vous demande de vous arrêter
alors bruno gaccio on vous présente plus
à rester bien dommage
dans cette émission tous les quinze
jours donc on va arrêter de vous
présenter à chaque fois pas seulement
tous les quinze jours
je sais pas lionel dutemple alors vous
on se présente à lionel dutemple j'ai 36
ans je travaille air france ouais
13 vous êtes pilote d'avion non chef
avion c'est moi qui dirige les a vus à
l'accorte rien ça plane pour vous quoi
exactement
très bien ahmed hamidi vous vous
présentez soir ahmed hamidi 33 ans
j'aime les parents je suis pour l'entrée
de la turquie en europe
alors bruno gaccio il ya deux semaines
vous étiez là pour le guignol et le
magistrat vous revenez aujourd'hui pour
l'année les guignols le dvd en deux
semaines vous avez fait comme une
émission de télé bruno 2 1 c'est tout
ouais j'ai fait ardisson et pascale
clark en aparté parce que c'est une très
très bonne émission n'est pas fatigant
d'affaires en même temps un vous avez
vendu combien de livres
la tentation c'est de répondre je suis
pas libre et c'est pas moi qui les vend
des livres j'ai entendu parler de ces
deux bouquins rendu à peu près à peu
près vous avez pris combien de petit
déjeuner auquel cost pour parler avec
des journalistes
j'ai pas pris tous les petits déjeuners
des fois je suis parti au mieux de la
nuit d'accor en deux semaines vous avez
fait l'amour combien de fois 0
l'amour à la mort j'ai fait l'amour 0
froid ils n'ont pas si ça va pas venir
j'en ai paniqué un paquet d'accords je
vous ai manqué ah ouais
aussi
[Musique]
alors le dvd l'année des guignols un
jean-pierre ça peut tout faire
donc c'est l'utilisation de jean pierre
raffarin sur la couverture du dvd c'est
une contrebasse mais vous l'utilisez
pour faire des phares des phares à vente
de chevaux des ja que chirac qui s'en
sert comme premier ministre finalement
il peut servir à bien d'autres trucs ce
mec là vous diriez quoi pour qu'on
l'achète le dvd acheté le sinon on est
viré
ouais et comme ça je pourrais faire
l'amour au moins deux fois par semaine
alors on va voir à quoi ça ressemble à
ce que voulaient bien regarder votre
caméra en dix ans tous les trois
ensemble
magnéto serge 3,4 magnéto serge bien
[Musique]
voilà c'est raffarin qu'est le premier
ministre ça va tu as eue en vacances
dans les vosges
qu'est ce qu'il ya je vais au canada
c'est comme les vosges mais en bon oui
petit jeu vous dérange un moment rien de
grave mais où me signale que des vieux
meurt à cause de la canicule la le 8
août on m'a dit 3000 là on al qassam il
imite le neuf ont fait croire sinon ça
va être la pagaille non mais je parlais
en cam de santé publique
1 on sait rien je suis pas docteur
essais valançon wii et plus de 40 avec
des pointes à 45 g et c'est en ce
qu'elle attend ça doit être là climat je
suis pas sorti de la chance wimille et
les vieux meurt la fin c'est bien tu le
regardes ton problème de retraites non
mais je suis sérieux je ne suis pas
inquiet mais beaucoup de personnes âgées
souffrent de la chaleur sophie
s'hydrater meurt on fait quoi
les vieux souffrent de la chaleur est il
maintenant un vieux sammer quoi qu'il
arrive joue pas chaud inquiète pas je
vérifier ça va
au froid à les arroser mes mais elle est
tout rouge bien oui bon je vais vérifier
la chaleur ça tue pas tous les vieux on
ne fait rien alors c'est on envoie
bachelot a expliqué vous êtes sûr
abordés sur de rigoler déjà garé sa
voiture à l'ombre elle tout c'est mal ça
valait tarn est saluée par étaient mes
vacances pour sa fille que la sarkozie a
accusé le gouvernement jospin d'avoir
fait passer la france pour un pays
antisémite cisco dell est si grave que
ministres perdent aussi son sang froid
et nous a insultés et demander des
excuses si minimum j'exige des excuses
et aussi de quoi qu'est ce qu'elle à la
petite [ __ ] la d excuse moi tu y
aller voilà les excuses j'étais pose est
celle née mais excuse moi ça va faire
des lunettes
quel scandale et je sarkozy ou de fous
c'est quoi ce nouveau ton coin
j'entendais voilà ça vient d'où cette
fois de [ __ ] la hausse et un journal
daté
à une [ __ ] endimanchés qui se met du
maquillage un bouge pas de là j'arrive
j'ai passé la gueule au chalumeau moi
monsieur chirac on a l'impression que
vous restez sourds aux cris du peuple
français
le roi va répondre qu'est ce qui vous
fait dire ça rien enfin quand même le
message des français est clair les
français ont dit non à jean pierre
raffarin
le roi va répond monsieur debré c'est
pénible
monsieur chirac et bien eu à votre
sanction là le roi va répondre c'est une
élection locale et à élections locales
conséquences locales
non mais là c'est plus que ça toutes les
régions basculer à gauche
et si on additionne toutes les agences à
fait bien la france c'est donc nationale
le roi est dans la merde pour répond la
notion tapas des deux ter la le roi va
choisir le ministre des finances c'est
toi je ne veux pas le roi s'en fout
voilà ma faute on commence par un record
du monde c'est dédiée hier au journal de
13h de tf1 notre regrettable confrère
jean pierre pernaut a battu le record du
monde de vitesse de traitement d'une
info nationale attention ça va aller
très vite et puis justice emplois
fictifs de la mairie de paris 27
prévenus sont au tribunal aujourd'hui
parmi lesquels alain juppé sport
maintenant avec caveau jean-pierre 1,7
seconde dans un journal national pour
une info qui fait la une partout
chapeau merci mais je ne suis pas seul
c'est un travail d'équipé
je tiens à ce titre a remercié etienne
mougeotte et patrick le lay qui m'ont
permis de battre ce record
je remercie aussi les français qui n'ont
pas de mémoire politique je remercie
star académie qui lobotomise le peu de
mémoire qui le reste et je remercie bien
évidemment bien évidemment ma conscience
qu'ils me laissent dormir en paix
surtout surtout je remercie les gens qui
continue à m'appeler journalistes
merci à tous
id numéro 9 une contrebasse
20 janvier complique toujours voilà
l'année des guignols un jean-pierre ça
peut tout faire
le dvd les messieurs
quand vous voyez ça vous pensez à la
sueur qui est derrière chez moi j'étais
pas là moi c'est non mais ça nous fait
quoi ça nous fait beaucoup moins rigoler
que quand on l'a sorti dans le bureau
mais c'est un peu comme ça c'est un peu
comme ça tous les jours c'est à dire que
ça nous fait beaucoup plus marrer
l'après midi quand on essaie de chercher
la vanne plutôt que le soir qu'on s'est
diffusée ouais c'est un peu normal dans
des gens aussi pareil j'ai remarqué en
relisant toutes vos interviews pour
préparer cette émission que vous posez
toujours les mêmes questions
alors je vais faire pareil on va les
faire une fois pour toute et ça serait
la dernière fois que vous y répondre est
d'accord ok le problème c'est que vous
avez 30 secondes maximum pour répondre
serge tu prends des tops à 30 secondes
une coupe quand on a un peu ton tout
penser oui
non ce n'est les outils pour penser oui
vu à l'imec argumenté un peu voûté pour
inviter toutes les deux semaines chez
redit son attention
doit-on tout dire top oui non présentant
des numéros de cirque alors par alors
moi je suis je suis méfiant dans les
guignols donc si on a les outils et
qu'il en reste un petit peu de ces
outils qu'on tourne à penser et ben oui
on peut tout dire mais il faut pouvoir
articuler sa pensée et c'est comme ça
tous les jours
vachement de genval marrante oui mais tu
comprends si jamais tu vois c'est
insupportable donc doit-on tout dire tu
pense que oui toi ouais je pense qu'on
peut tu penses que gollnisch avait
raison ah ah ouais mais la joie une
autre question les autres questions
c'est une autre question
vas-y tu penses que gollnisch a eu
raison de dire ce qu'elle avait je pense
pas qu'il a raison de dire ce qu'il a
dit je pense qu'il a le droit de le dire
pour peu qu'on puisse à la fois le
critiquer a porté un matériel critique
suffisant pour les gens qui pourraient
de son avis et c'est là c'est simple
c'est ça la liberté d'expression c'est
de pouvoir laisser s'exprimer les gens
avec qui on n'est absolument pas
d'accord encore faut-il pouvoir les
contredire dans un dans un cadre
pour prier et même encore du temps mais
dis moi et beauty l'yonne la le
commissaire européen qui dit que
finalement l'homosexualité c'est un
péché que les enfants ont besoin d'une
maman et tout ça il a le droit de le
dire mais lui c'est un italien il a tous
les droits
[Applaudissements]
à la question la plus con ella plus
passe partout
est-ce que l'humour est forcément drôle
top si c'est moi qui fait des vannes non
moi je veux répondre oui oui la preuve
que non c'est vous apporte encore la
preuve alors je vous souhaite chiant
[Musique]
s'il y en a une en reste est ce que est
ce que bruno gaccio réussite vous
touchez dessin top oui non
[Musique]
alors on va maintenant passer quelques
coups de fil master là on tombe sur le
répondeur interview répondeur bonjour
bonjour j'ai bien j'ai bien lescure je
vais bien merci
je bosse sur la 5e et j'ai vendu tous
mes meubles laissez moi un message bip
j'ai vu ce que tu veux sur la cinquième
c'est pas mal qui devrait prendre une
chaîne de télé oui bonjour vous êtes
bien chez monsieur madame gaccio oui on
est les parents me désole laissez un
message bip je t'appelle demain je te
jure
bonjour vous êtes bien chez michèle
bernier si vous n'êtes pas bruno gaccio
laissé un message bip
je ne suis pas bruno gaccio moi je suis
bruno gaccio g comment vont les enfants
michel bonjour vous êtes bien chez
florent pagny vous pouvez me laisser un
message
mais vous n'aurez pas ma liberté de
pensée bip moi je dirais excuses -
laurent florent excuses je me suis gouré
alors je sais j'ai fait un faux numéro
je voulais appeler quelqu'un d'autre en
forêt je l'appellerai bonjour c'est bien
chez le procureur philippe bilger
je suis parti faire le guignol à la télé
et bruno gaccio laissez moi un message
bip est plus drôle que bruno gaccio
bonjour vous êtes bien c'est jacques et
bernadette chirac si vous avez des
pièces jaunes laissez nous un message
bip jeudi à l'heure de la retraite en
vrai en vrai vous vivez ensemble donc
[Rires]
bonjour vous êtes bien chez patrick
sébastien je me suis fait une tête de
répondeur c'est génial pouvez laisser un
message bip continue à faire des
émissions de service public c'était
juste pour dire ça que je te plaît et je
dirais j'aime bien les saltimbanques
il est bien et ce qui est vrai bonjour
vous êtes bien c'est jean marie le pen
je voulais sortir avec ma fille laissez
moi un message b jean-marie je voudrais
bien sortir avec ta fille puis
j'aimerais bien que tu sortes avec ta
fille que tu sortes du pays avec ta
fille que tu sois bonjour bonjour vous
êtes bien chez guillaume durand [ __ ]
je bosse comme un fou
laissez moi un message de pardon tu
bosse comme un fou ouais j'ai un bon
jour c'est bien chez laurent baffie si
vous avez vu mon film laissez moi un
message bip
j'ai pas vu ton filmeront mais je veux
j'attends qu'il sorte en dvd ouais c'est
bientôt en plus laurence et gaccio
arrête de faire la gueule
un bonjour j'ai bien chez lionel jospin
je vais revenir laissez-moi messagerie
mais revient lionel revient ah ouais bah
oui tu me kiffe abus selon de tu veux
quoi non peut-être un autre mais qui il
va rien comprendre au message là bonjour
vous êtes bien ses heures je bouge je
sais que c'est incroyable laissez moi un
message bip ls gagné qui arrive alors je
t'attends pas à l'aise gagné kerry on te
dit je laisse gagner kerry ouais georges
laisse gagner kerry oui bah oui mais non
mais de l'avis du monde en dépend je
voudrais c'est vrai oui non c'est
pourquoi on s'intéresse à l'art aux
élections et finalement une médiation de
l'eau bonjour vous êtes bien chez
l'association des personnes de petite
taille de france si vous n'êtes pas trop
grand laissez moi un message mais pour à
m je vous dis qu'au basket d'accord
bonjour j'ai bien chez elvis presley
laissez moi un message on sait jamais
bip
quand est ce que tu fais un disque
revient revient vite ils sont tous
devenus fous ils ont laissé le
rock'n'roll à pagny
bienvenue
lol
à 18 ans la vie des thèmes communs
[Musique]
voici pascal sevran et allan
voilà pascal sevran et alan je vois je
vois tu as call que vous portez votre
légion d'honneur
oui je te réponds venir chez toi ça
faisait plus chez bien on peut voir de
voirie sur deux guerres bon on peut voir
votre blessure de guerre
la mérite agricole non pourquoi pas je
viens alors résumé des épisodes
précédents pascal a organisé sur france
2 un concours de chanteurs et de
chanteuses intitulé entrée d'artistes
5000 candidats 400 audition 40
sélectionné quatorze finalistes et un
vainqueur allan
les tenir
on voit des garçons
cousez des garçons
[Musique]
ils sont
des enfants qui sont serge
quand
les inquiets pour les quatre 1999 contre
ça tu es de michery la sélection écoute
bien le début
oui
m
les filles aiment défi à l'âme j'ai bien
compris pascal filles mes filles
c'est une chanson qui avait créé des
leaders ya trente ans que françois ozon
a repris dans son film et kahlan a
entendu dans ce sens ce film m'a proposé
de la chanter chansons ont créé par
dalida qui n'avait pas exactement son
âge à ce moment là et j'ai été étonné le
voir qu'il avait choisi cette chanson il
la chantait je te reconnais beaucoup de
d'intensité les téléspectateurs l'ont
pensé aussi je continue à le penser
voilà ça dort je n'ai pas uniquement une
question je te réponds voilà d'accord
t'as pas la voix de pompe physique
méthane belle voix mais t'as pas la
boîte ton physique
[Musique]
ouais et en plus on ne peut pas vivre
seul des filles aiment des filles de
notre faute
voilà c'est ça qu'il entendait c'est
vachement bien ces choix ne sais pas si
tu as quel âge là j'ai 17 ans à penser
des trucs voilà alors ce morceau ce
morceau ce morceau est extrait de la
compil officiel entrée d'artistes vous
connaissez orlando alan je le connais un
petit peu puisque je connais un petit
peu le parcours d'hélène ségara way et
don carlo forcément vous savez qu
orlando exige le clip vous savez ça vous
vous teniez comme mitterrand il ya des
références plus déplaisante que celle là
non je n'en ai pas et sait pas pourquoi
ben oui c'est juste pour montrer que je
me le diront jamais à l'abri de solutré
avec ou ctv pour dire j'ai à bruno
gaccio tout le monde le sait bien sûr
mais pourquoi c'est sa fidélité
référence au nord
voilà si sa fidélité à mitterrand sa
mère je vous préviens je pose des soucis
donc vous allez regarder votre caméra
l'âme et vous allez dire magnéto serge
magnéto serge
[Musique]
fait des cadrages vous tous
quel sens ça
chahine et toi
m
je t'aime et je t'attends on se donne
l'illusion de lepage
russell
voir alors
alors vous vous êtes le vainqueur et
analyses qui reprennent des grands
succès de la chanson française sur cette
compil entrée d'artistes et le clip il
est raté son déconner ben c'est pas un
clip c'est un extrait les initiants
blanc pascal quand je pense qu'on vous
reprochez de de faire chanter que des
vieillards finalement fait mentir la
légende c'est vrai ben vous voyez on
avait tort ouais j'ai toujours tout au
long de l'émission tv je fais plus
longtemps j'ai fait chanter toutes les
générations et est donc maintenant on y
refait je vais chanter aussi gras changé
je pensais que ça a pas l'air content qu
est ce que tu as non pas c'est à dire
que je ne sais pas tellement je suis
venu en voisin
et comme tu m'as fait l'amitié de
m'inviter j'étais content de venir pour
allan poe c'est impressionnant pour
laisser première émission de télévision
car quoi qu'on dise je crois qu'à très
grand père avant chez ce garçon et donc
je suis venu parce que tu m'as faire et
gentillesse de l'invité de l'inviter
sans ça je fais très peu d'émissions de
télévision comme tu le fais et je n'ai
pas du tout envie de venir faire des
gugusses rit donc je réponds aux
questions tu me poses
mais s'il s'agit de faire le clown ça
n'est pas mon métier tiens et panneaux
relatant a compris oui alors arrête de
me prêter
c'est pas non plus une raison pour faire
la gueule je veux dire je ne fais pas la
gueule je réponds été question avec
plaisir je suis content d'être là
j'écoute tes questions vous et moi ici
sacherie palladium existait super six il
s'agit s'il s'agit de ce petit jeu là je
connais par coeur je connaissais depuis
longtemps sa télévision
c'est bien ça s'amuse aussi mais quand
je suis chez moi va je zappe un petit
peu mais ça me fatigue un peu
un don au casier j'étais cool dre près
ce que tu veux ce qu en général question
sont pas forcément stupide bien
alors pascal vous allez écrire une
chanson pour le premier album à une
feinte sourira
bon j'ai eu mon premier sourire c'est
bien mais je la donne plus regardent les
yeux qu'il a je l'aï tourné ensemble
qu'on voit du vin blanc quoi parle
littérature et politique et ce soir on
ne lui parlait un peu chanson oui il
veut pas d'exaspérer longtemps pose moi
ta question je réponds maintenant base
d'accord alors la question c'est pascal
s'ils n'ont pas une question d'ailleurs
vous allez écrire une chanson pour le
premier album de dahlan ça fait
longtemps que vous n'avez pas écrit de
chansons j'ai pas écrit de chansons
depuis très longtemps je ne suis pas sûr
que je vais en écrire
voilà donc peut-être à une chanson c'est
pas l'objet je ne suis pas le producteur
de la tournée je suis pas le producteur
de disques c'est pas l'auteur des
chansons suis là je suis l'homme qui
fait de son mieux pour sur le service
public
ouvrir une fenêtre sur une génération
ils sont pas mal c'est simple dit saint
nicolas
alors
vous avez déclaré en parlant d' alan il
brûle un feu intérieur et ça se voit
quand il sourit oui vous savez il y
avait comme ça 7 500 audition et puis un
moment donné voilà on se dit c'est lui
ou c'est elle est évidemment c'était lui
voilà je ne suis pas absolument abrutis
quand je parle de chanteurs aussi
intéressant que bruno gaccio 1 quand ils
parlent de liberté d'expression est
aussi drôle alors alan ont parlé d' alan
maintenant à l'âne vous êtes originaire
de la somme d'un petit village qui
s'appelle friville escarbotin et
maintenant tu es à paris 4126 habitants
voilà vos parents michel et michel
possède une petite entreprise de
rondelle alors messi tous les leviers
voilà ses dépenses et personne ne dira
explique vasile centre des tubes en fait
à fond la robinetterie des rares cas pas
le père chanteur ou la mère chanteurs ou
comédiens affaire qui fait l'étude donc
c'est bien pour lui encore trois quarts
d'heure il fait des vagues commencent à
être dissous risque des jeunes ma
famille quand même deux musiciens votre
père joue de la guitare et du trombone
votre grand-père du saxophone votre
soeur du pipeau savoir pareil que
précédemment on les pensait alors quand
vous apprenez l'existence du casting de
pascal sevran vous hésitez pas ce que
voulait pas commencer par la télévision
pourquoi ce que gérant jamais couru les
castings jamais été très attiré par ça
et j'ai tenté ma chance par presque par
hasard et je me suis rendu compte après
que c'était vraiment une très bonne
opportunité sur un an chez pascal sevran
ans le jour du casting vous chantez
amsterdam et s'appelait pas parce
qu'alain il est très sec avec vous je
suis arrivé j'ai eut demandé de chanter
il m'a demandé ce que je vais chanter
j'ai dit amsterdam il m'a finances même
chanson pour toi évidemment quand je
voyais ce petit garçon dire amsterdam je
trouve que c'était une chanson trop
grande pour lui
j'ai voulu qui s'exprime d'abord ce
répertoire à lui on verra après
il est évident que c'est évident que ça
me parait brel c'est très difficile on
peut pas comme ça voilà donc je lui ai
dit attends pour on verra plus tard et
tu as chanté quoi chanter je te le dis
quand même de patrick bruel jean
françois avait trop chanté une mère de
départ à lui a pas trop mal réussi ni à
patrick brunet d'ailleurs autant pascal
avait été sec au casting au temps après
il a été chaleureux il nous a beaucoup
appris à tous à tous mes copains
d'ailleurs ils sont ils sont là derrière
entre copains très amis et c'est vrai
que depuis le début il nous a dit ion il
vous conseille vous conseille vous mais
quoi jeudi pour relier les champs nord
il a rien dit par le codis a confié m
comme lui je remarque ici se sont
habillés comme il voulait ouais je les
fais ok puis sont venus comme isabey
envie de venir enfin tout ça c'est qu'on
va les voir
bonjour
nous pensons
le clip hot on ne touche en rien avec
medion elles sont quand même pas mal
mais ce qui me sens très bien
vous me souviens toi dont vous êtes la
nouvelle bande de pascal sevran
ouais vous avez vous changé quelque
chose là alors amsterdam 6 c'est tout à
fait une chanson de groupe ça te fait il
ya une chanson bridge joie si vous
tombez amoureux de chansons chantées à
mener
devant laval a dit mon époux
n'importe où
ou pas
merci
[Musique]
poussant par alain tu te fais plein de
nouveaux copains avec cette émission
finalement ils sont très bien
ouais ils sont très bien je dis pas ici
a très bien même si tu m'a annoncé la
mort de quelqu'un non parce qu'on peut
semaine à bord de la chanson déjà je
prends très au sérieux je veux dire ils
ont comme ça ils sont ils font ça très
bien c'est vrai qu'ils sont ils sont
très bien ils sont émus ils sont
contents et ça me donne pas envie de
faire de la plaisanterie là dessus voilà
supergrave
c'est grave sans déconner cela je hais
les chanteurs de la jeunesse et la
passion la jeunesse et la passion que
met ces jeunes gens à leur métier c'est
en effet très important
donc je suis content de voir les
parrainer chez j'ai tiré ce soir alors
alan pascal ne s'est pas contenté de
donner votre chance il vous donne aussi
des conseils alors justement on va tous
en profitent et pascal quels conseils
donneriez-vous à un jeune chanteur qui
débute d'abord une détermination
formidable c'est l'idée qu'on ne veut
faire ça et rien d'autre deuxième chose
ne surtout pas s'occuper d'être à la
mode parce que là c'est raté comme un
nombre à peu près dans toute l'histoire
de la chanson française
mais ils sont à l'abri de ça écoutez je
retire ma phrase parce que sans ça je
finis ma phrase il s'agit des jeunes
gens moi j'en ai rien à faire je ne
viens pas refaire le bus ici je finis ma
phrase et je hais je vous dis que il n'y
a pas d'exemple quasiment de vedette de
music hall de la chanson française qui
ont qui sont arrivés en semoule ans en
se couchant dans la mode voilà alors
vous ne posez une question j'essaie je
vous réponds du club moi aussi donc
l'idée simplement pas ce cas va aller
courir parce que dans la mode parce que
le temps de la rattraper elle est déjà
passé d'accord quels conseils
donneriez-vous un vieux chanteur qui
débute encore d'être en bonne santé
chanteuse plus longtemps parce que il
faut il faut pas un poids y ait said ces
adjectifs qui rit vieux vous allez être
bientôt que je suis donc pas bien quels
conseils donneriez-vous à pascal sevran
jeune je donnerai un conseil à pascal
sevran queue à cette heure ci loi de
coucher bonsoir
voilà
[Musique]
affaire parce qu'elle se rend mon pote
jean reno alors savoir chanter mais
apparemment quels conseils
donneriez-vous à pascal sevran jeunes de
continuer à faire ce qu'il a fait parce
que mine de rien il a servi la chanson
française une certaine façon en chanson
française que je n'achète pas et que je
n'achèterai sans doute jamais mais au
moins il a servi à ça la télévision et
continue sa part d'une banane quels
conseils donneriez-vous un chanteur qui
ne veut pas de conseils de pascal sevran
et ben écoute parce qu'elles souffrent
c'est pas des conseils bien est-ce que
la lame connais bien la chanson
française vous croyez maïs icônes et
amsterdam de brel il connaît la chanson
française vient jamais toi là tu fais à
la nallet tu fais ce grand site et
compte sur moi pour faire sur ma fille à
la place de secondes sinon ma pour moi
si tu veux un collier ahmed
non c'est bien est-ce que alan que vais
bien ma chanson française
alan connaîtra demain la chanson
française y est ce que alan c'est que
charles trenet nous a quittés à l'âge ne
sait pas que charles trenet nous a
quittés il faut pas lui dire pascal
année sensible syrie est-ce que alors on
va faire un petit jeu là là je vais vous
dire des chanteurs si vous allez me dire
mort ou pas mort d'accord aller allons-y
reggiani morpho et heureusement
mouloudji morts richard anthony vivant
nino ferrer mort bien l'âme bien il
connaît bien la chanson du fener
georges moustaki vivant vivent très bien
à l'âme
est ce que pascal vous a déjà dit tu
sais tu as un truc que bruel n'avait pas
à ses débuts
enfin c'est que j'ai d'avoir un terrain
contigu snh en écoute rascal skz à la
gueule
non je suis désolé
[Musique]
g bâle heigl fait
non
ça va aller fais moi ton beau sourire
pascal je suis venu ici pour répondre à
des questions je parle de musique ok
donc je répondrai à vos questions
monsieur ambitions j'irai jusqu'au bout
est ce que parce qu'elle vous a déjà dit
c'est un album je prends 80 et wav un
jeu il m'a dit on prend au jeu prend 80
et tu prendras et j'ai dit oui de
tueries ces questions me demander mais
qu'est ce qu'un préaccord rigaux
ces questions sont sont très très
dérangeant raison qui est simple c'est
que je ne suis pas le producteur je ne
suis pas l'autre je sais que je suis
mais tu mets tes mains comme mitterrand
c'est marrant mais c'est un hommage
c'est quelqu'un que j'aimais beaucoup il
ya des références beaucoup plus
désagréable impression d'avoir déjà vécu
cette scène c'est marrant alors est ce
que pascal sevran vous a déjà dit
attends tu vas pas passer à la télé
habillée comme ça quand même
oui mais je vous dis tu peux faire tout
ce que tu veux mais je garde le collier
[Rires]
est ce que pascal seulement vous ai déjà
dit tu vas voir ardisson c'est un gros
con mais au fond il est sympa comme il y
en a plus à des mots il ya des moments
où il faut essayer de raison garder
parce que je sais au maximum de faire ce
pour quoi nous européens
alors maintenant vous verrez vous verrez
alan pascal sevran est un match ici on
va faire une interview baguette bien
alors pascal sevran vous mettriez qui à
la tête du ministère de la culture
j'écoutais thierry je ne sais pas quoi
dire peut-être - oui vous feriez passé
quelle loi l'assemblée pascal il y à il
ya tellement de choses à faire comme
disait françois mitterrand
il faudrait des siècles pour faire pour
mener à bien tout ce qu'on a voulu faire
un vrai nom mais je ne suis pas venu ici
pour faire du gugusse je suis désolé je
encore une question comme ça je m'en
vais non j'arrête
moi je le suis vous enverriez quelle
émission de la grille des programmes si
vous aviez une baguette magique pascal
il y en a trop il y en a trop enlevé
mais il ne faut rien enlever la liberté
si on avait enlevé les miennes une
époque où vraiment la france avait
besoin de chance on avait besoin de
dalida avait besoin d' orlando avait
besoin de qu'aznavour bien sûr de qui
seraient fournis par les passes à vous
face à vous ils vous regardent rêve ou
fusillé du regard vous n'avez plus rien
à dire si la ramène moi bruno gaccio si
la ferme ta gueule
ce pas une bien sûr bien si vous aviez
une baguette magique pascal vous
retrouveriez immédiatement quelle
période de votre vie
j'ai écrit un livre là-dessus
j'aimerais retrouver cette période s'est
vraiment passé
pascal si vous aviez une baguette
magique vous ne referiez pas quelle
erreur je ne ferai pas l'erreur de venir
ici non préparés sans savoir qu'il y à
cette table d'accord vous changeriez
quoi la couleur de vos cheveux pascal si
vous aviez une baguette magique je suis
obligé de répondre ah non mais je ne
changerais rien à la couleur de mes
cheveux peut-être à leur forme
ouais je ferai quelque chose de moi
balayé à lardy son recul à quelque chose
de plus hardis sonné sq d'aujourd'hui
vous changeriez quoi chez vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique un profil que
je ne veux pas qu'on filme à c'est
l'autre oui ça te sens bien je suppose
ce soir
[Musique]
confie de l'émission ne serait ce qu'une
seconde à messieurs avec alan
[Musique]
et maintenant j'en ai mis le changement
majeur en 2006 marina foïs et puff
elle était là
ouais bravo merci marine à paris
en effet voilà vous connaissez à la main
à la main le petit protégé de le petit
protégé de pascal sevran
parce qu'elle voulait mais parce qu'elle
sevran perf à mais je connais pas bien
mais je vois j'aime bien le personnage
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui dise
qu'ils pensent voilà donc j'aime bien
les gens qui disent qu'ils pensent
pouvoir comique extraordinaire alors
vous êtes ici ce soir pour vous êtes ici
ce soir
vous êtes ici ce soir pour un livre
signé par les robins des bois qui
s'appelle l'histoire de france 2 avant a
maintenant chez canal+ édition marina
est une des seules femmes enceintes
alcoolique
ça sera ça
m
c'est la chanteuse préférée après janis
joplin
je ne pense pas qu'il soit maire de
faire l'apologie l'apologie du de
l'alcoolisme pour réussir dans l'achat
en fait là c'était bruno gaccio
dis moi c'est le seul moyen que tu as
trouvé pour avoir de grosses pincettes
tomber enceinte
oui alors bon puisqu'on parle de mes
seins tout de suite gens très contente
c'est même pas tellement vrai si vous
voulez la vérité ils ont pas tellement
grossi ces détresses 1 vous avez touché
perf pour nom mais je peux toucher mais
le reste ça peut être vulgaire mais
comme c'est une vieille amie et alors eh
ben c'est dur c'est à dire que moi il y
en a plus c'est dur c'est normal avons
nous vraiment tu as des jolies
chaussures merci alors là c'est les prix
des métaux comme tu es de souvient
encore le marina
est-ce que désormais vous vous sentez
plus femme au fond de vous ouais je
crois que rosemère c'est le plus beau
jour de ma vie
est ce que le regard des hommes a changé
sur vous marrez na waie alors alors je
voudrais annoncer aux filles et si vous
comptez vous faire draguer quand vous
êtes enceinte c'est loupé ah bon ouais
ça marche plus du tout pas du tout mais
dit faisait draguer quand tu étais
enceinte la région vous avez des ça vous
vous sentez plus proche de fil twitter
ouais vous pensez que les robins savez
que vous devez avoir un enfant marina
bay je leur ai demandé l'autorisation
bien sûr ainsi qu'un rapport sexuel à
chacun mais je ne sais plus qui a gagné
ah bon on va vite le voir un si petit et
chauvin vous pensez qu'il s'en rendrait
compte que vous étiez une femme qui
désiraient avoir un enfant non parce que
c'est vrai qu'ils m'ont toujours vu
comme un auteur et
f
oh non ainsi attention ça est sûre
tessin et j'ai déjà l'un des plus gros
que marina en plus divers donc oui au
sein oui c'est vrai que par rapport à
mes seins si j'ai décidé de pas faire
d'enfant c'était pour qu'ils restent
tels que je sais pas si vous dire tel
quel ou tu as eu coup alors j'ai dit ok
disons qu'ici ce soir pour mon avis de
l'histoire drôle livres 10 noms un livre
d'histoire avec un grand h
une histoire de la france dont notre
joli pays aux mille fromages virgule
livre qui est drôle pareil si vous
utilisez très peu de mots à un mot
francs comprend pas le sens de ce que
vous dites est ce que voulait bien nous
en détail et du contenu
est ce que vous voulez bien maison
détaillé oui je prenais une inspire
avant de parler c'est normal voilà
écoutez ça s'appelle déjà
l'histoire de france 2 avant a
maintenant c'est un livre assez
exhaustif sur donc tout ce qui s'est
passé dans notre pays depuis qu'il
existe
c'est la ligne éditoriale c'est vraiment
un souci de vérité
en gros tout est vrai à part les faits
et les dates
c'est un livre qui est destiné à toutes
les personnes qui désirent perpétuer
leur ignorance
c'est à dire les robins des bois par
exemple peut faire si six livres achetés
ça va à l'âme
ça va pas mal écoute
adam back sur le port d'amsterdam avait
apporté à mme stern non je peux pas je
peux pas faire ça c'est sûr parce que je
pense que c'est si atroce parce que j'ai
pas le costume pour chanter amsterdam
aussi il ya des dealers de shit
moi j'ai jamais grandi ici
est ce que c'est vrai marina que alain
decaux a voulu vous casser la gueule les
gens vous suivent et à l'année sui ahmed
suis pas mal refaire une interview alain
decaux raconte on se concentre en tant
que spécialiste vous allez nous répondre
louis xiv était il mieux que louis xiii
et louis xiv et est divisible ce qui
n'est pas le cas de louis xiii oui louis
xiii était premier en fait c'est
l'ancien régime et est il efficace
non si un régime c'était à base de thé
popopopops way témoignages ou habitant
le plus de chance de croiser des gens
chauprade meubles folie trois bonnes
réponses
bonne réponse de marina que sa grossesse
ne m'empêche pas d'avoir de l'esprit
pourquoi at on pris la bastille le 14
juillet ben ça c'est évident alors ça on
n'a pas eu besoin de potasser pour le
savoir parce que comme si tu étais un
jour férié du 14 juillet tout le monde
était libre pour pour aller prendre
cette île est ce que ça valait le coup
de prendre la bastille en même temps
pour remettre l'opéra à la place ce
n'est pas non c'est pas très malin
quelle est la particularité du château
de chambourcy
il a vraiment de quoi était inspiré
d'une histoire vraie celle instar du
premier crime de l'humanité
mais pareil ça c'est toujours parce que
nous on a une réputation de légèreté
tout mais pareilles erreurs on a fait
une enquête on a retrouvé le premier
criminel de l'humanité en a raconté son
histoire et c'est bien mais c'est sortir
devait bien ouais quand est apparue
résine régine la chanteuse
à la renaissance bravo ou et il est plus
facile de faire un créneau
bon ça dans un château un château en
château fort et j'ai noué doigts dans le
nez voilà j'ai compris c'est là qu'est
ce qui fait toute la journée avec voulu
je ne s'imprime s'est pas expliqué aux
membres les yeux que je suis en train de
me dire qu'il est temps a eu encore une
fois de changer l'équipe - magotan
entend faut le faire là il faut spurs
obligé c'est toi qui as tu vas pouvoir
de vie et de mort sur le parking dit
dégage par exemple je te gâche la
existe-t-il d'autres types de château
les châteaux faible c'est une sorte de
château de sable donc ses partisans qui
avaient pas les moyens mais qui n'est
pas très costaud calais pas la muscu
voilà c'est des châteaux faible mais
allah ni les bourdons sympa il et il
hérite du canada mais coup je fais pas
mal enfin franchement je pense que vous
avez manqué de respect à pascal 1 mais
je reste et je représente c'est bien
qu'ils le successeur de napoléon c'est
serge lama enfin bien que signifie la
quarantaine pour un homme que c'est
bientôt fini
aulas alors pascal d'où vient le nom de
la 4l
ben ça vient d'henri iv en fait bien
qu'ils avaient également pour les pros
les gens les plus riches avaient créé le
henry henry qui est devenu le 4 4 mais
moi je veux avoir vu
ça donne envie de l'acheter
que signifie 15 15 ben sassi sa
sénégalité ses bons mots tennis voilà
très bien c'est aussi aussi marignan
mais c'est marignane c'est marie voilà
des mois
l'histoire de france
c'est ce qu'avait plus
il y en a
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant eric laurent
mais
[Musique]
merrigan bonsoir ce soir vous connaissez
tous le monde
alan bonsoir pascal sevran
lionel dutemple marina foïs et pef voilà
eric laurent grand reporter spécialiste
de politique étrangère auteurs de
plusieurs best-sellers dont la guerre
des bouches et le monde secret de bouche
qui ont été adapté pour le cinéma la
télévision avec un grand succès vous
revenu aujourd'hui avec la face cachée
du 11 septembre publié chez plon
alors si une enquête que vous avez
menées dans le monde entier pendant dix
mois
vous avez découvert une série de
mensonges d'une gravité inouïe
on commence avec l'arrestation de ben
laden
le 5 avril 2003 le général myers chef
d'état major de l'armée américaine a
déclaré l'objectif n'a jamais été de
capturer ben laden général myers qui
donc est chef d'état major de l'armée
américaine a fait cette déclaration
d'ailleurs en présence de donald
rumsfeld le chef du pentagone
et il était d'ailleurs extrêmement bas
c'est évidemment après il a démenti mais
malheureusement le mal était fait et
évidemment c'est un trouble et beaucoup
de monde pourquoi le général mayer se
déclare-t-il ça mais moi mon avis pour
une raison très simple c'est que je
crois qu'on ait fait l'objectif n'avait
jamais été à attraper ben laden parce
que parce que bon les enjeux autour du
11 septembre sont beaucoup plus trouble
beaucoup plus complexe a été d'ailleurs
effectivement l'objet de l'enquète et
c'est vrai qu'on voit se dessiner même
avant le 11 septembre
un certain nombre d'éléments qui sont
mes plus que troublants qu'ils soient
vraiment dérangeante
on apprend par exemple en lisant votre
bouquin que ben laden n'a toujours pas
été inculpé pour le 11 septembre
alors ça c'est une grande surprise je
feuillette le dossier de bin laden je
regarde la fiche donc il ya toutes les
indications gauche et marche avec une
canne sans profession enfin tout est
répertorié jeu quand même très surpris
je me dis la fiche n'est pas mise à jour
je vérifie et effectivement je
m'aperçois que ni l'attentât contre
l'urss cole vous savez le
american women exactement en 2000 n'est
mentionnée est évidemment encore moins
les 11 septembre
je m'adresse donc os biya et je demande
à quelqu'un je connais au
contre-terrorisme au et biya il me dit
que tu es c'est un vrai problème pour
nous parce que figurez-vous que le fbi
avec dépend du ministère de la justice
américain
et depuis le 11 septembre 2001 monsieur
john ashcroft et a dû très proche
collaborateur de bush n'a jamais
effectivement lancé d'avis de recherche
fédéral contre oussama ben laden alors
attendez le général maillard se déclare
que l'objectif n'a jamais été d'arrêter
ben laden vous découvrez qu aucun mandat
d'arrêt n'a été lancée par les états
unis contre ben laden
pourquoi écoutez les explications tient
peut-être aussi au fait qu' il existe
des liens a tout de même extrêmement et
3 on peut dire plus étroits entre la
famille bush et la famille bin laden
on peut dire qu'il y a des liens
d'affaires entre les deux principales
dynastie au fond régnante
c'est à dire d'une part la dynastie bush
et notre part aussi la dynastie royale
saoudienne style qui est ce qui est
frappant quand on compte au creuset
concours mon enquête
c'est de voir à quel point en effet ses
liens d'affaires ces réseaux qui
existent maintenant depuis 10 15 ans
prime sur évidemment l'intérêt général
et sur la logique politique bien entendu
alors dans votre bouquin il ya la
fameuse forteresse de bora bora
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez mais
envoyer sur lci il y avait un plan en
coupe on voyait de montagne qui était
entièrement creusé avec des ascenseurs
il est des portes blindées tout était
extraordinaire james bond voilà c'était
complètement james bond c'est goldfinger
apparemment vous vous êtes allé dans
cette formation a refusé à tora bora est
donc effectivement donc incompétents
il faisait passer pour des temps des
vieux couvert et à tora bora ce qui est
tout à fait étonnant c'est que je suis
et jusqu'à la maison de ben laden
et c'est une maison en torchis et au
dessus de laquelle tout en longueur il
ya huit pièces à peu près et au dessus
de laquelle il ya en effet cinq petites
grottes et je suis allé dans ces cinq
grotte et 5 grottes sont cinq pauvres
infractuosités de deux mètres de
profondeur de 80 cm de haut et qui
sentent mais terriblement lui rinne
c'est tout y'a rien et quand j de demain
et aujourd'hui nos bons endroits et
quand j'ai demandé aux gens qui
m'accompagnent est l'équipe qui
m'accompagne et qui étaient des gens
d'ailleurs des afghans qui avaient
combattu bin laden
et quand j'aurai dit mais êtes-vous allé
à l'intérieur de la grande grotte vous
salle intérieure de tora bora où étaient
cachés bin laden ont fait répéter
plusieurs fois la question est quand
j'ai expliqué qu'en effet il y avait
effectivement en occident une
description extrait mars office tourisme
mondial était soi-disant dirigé exact de
mousse de vidéos oui mais ils ont éclaté
de rire ils ont éclaté de rire ils ont
trouvé que j'étais un formidable
plaisante j'ai présenté un budget un
truc parce qu'ils ont juste laisser les
toilettes ont fait un truc et c'est ça
je suis vous êtes tombé je vous ai
découvert on passe en revue tout ce que
vous avez découvert parce que vous avez
découvert des trucs il ya par exemple
les délits d'initiés c'est à dire qu'il
ya des gens qui étaient au courant du 11
septembre puisque des transactions
financières exactement absolument
incassable qua non écoutez c'est tout à
fait incroyable c'est à dire que dans
les jours qui ont précédé le 11
septembre 6 7 septembre et même le 10
septembre la veille des attentats
on a spéculé à la baisse ont acheté
massivement des actions des deux
compagnies aériennes dont les avions ont
été détournés pas d'autres compagnies
simplement united et american airlines
c'est à dire que cet effet avec un
cynisme incroyable ses doigts bon on a
misé effectivement donc sur la chute
évidemment de céder à un cours de ces
compagnies et ensuite le jour où la
bourse a été rouverte
les gains ont été considérables hier de
plusieurs dizaines de millions de
dollars
mais la chose face et de lancer que en
remontant un peu dire on arrive
effectivement tout a été évidemment que
complètement caché et par y compris par
les autorités américaines le fbi a eu
notamment la cia qui n'ont jamais laissé
filtrer la moindre information
mais j'ai réussi à retrouver
effectivement une banque d'affaires qui
a été effectué une des banques effet
acquis à effectuer donc une partie de
ses opérations et c'est une banque
d'affaires importante qui est une fille
est aujourd'hui de la deutsche bank
c'est avec ce drame alex prend
exactement et j'ai découvert
curieusement que l'ancien responsable de
cette bande pendant des années avait
démissionné juste avant d'ailleurs
et vous savez où il est maintenant il
est numéro 3 ne cia
il s'appelle belgique en garde et
c'était l'homme au sein de la cia
chargés de surveiller justement tous et
à toutes les situations anormales sur
les marchés financiers il ya un truc
c'est à dire c'est que la cia surveille
en temps réel 24 heures open car les
marchés financiers et ils ont pas ils
ont ils ont rien dit qu'en fait monsieur
crown garde qui était donc l'homme en
charge de cette opération n'a rien vu
rien entendu rien compris alors que
c'était évidemment un spécialiste des
finances
ils ont comme vous le dites laisse que
de la possibilité d'opérer en temps réel
ouais alors qu'il ya aussi la l'identité
des pirates de l'air on connaît toujours
pas en fait la véritable identité des
pirates de l'air cinq d'entre eux ont
usurpé l'identité de personnes encore
vivantes dites vous dans votre livre est
en fait ce que vous dites c'est quand
les mecs ont fait le coup il n'est pas
de tora bora là c'était des tips étaient
des saoudiens qui s'entraînait sur les
bases aériennes américaines en fait oui
et moi je suis anne effectivement
assisté à la dernière réunion de la
commission enquête le 17 juin donc à
washington et j'ai posé la question au
vice président qui s'appelle lee
hamilton je lui ai dit êtes vous
vraiment sûr à 100% l'identité des
pirates de là il m'a répondu oui nous
sommes sûrs à 100% ce qui est absolument
faux
car en effet comme vous le disait il ya
cinq personnes qui effectivement donc
ont vu leur identité usurpée par les
pirates de l'air cinq d'entre eux les
gens sont manifestés après l'attentât
ont dit écoutez je suis désolé j'ai
retrouvé ma photo j'ai retrouvé en effet
que j'ai retrouvé mon identité ça n'est
pas moi j'ai fait une déclaration de
perte ya maintenant trois ans je vis je
n'ai jamais quitté le maroc la tunisie
l'arabie saoudite le yémen et la
commission bancaire n'en a pas tenu
compte
on est exactement dans la même situation
encore une fois que j'écrive mans donc
l'assassinât de kennedy avec la
commission warren la commission d'
enquête sur le 11 septembre a totalement
effacé toute trace en effet les normes
et délits d'initiés que vous évoquez ne
sont pas contenues dans le rapport de la
commission les
dirais-je les doutes sur l'identité des
pirates de l'air non plus et il ya aussi
un point extrêmement important c'est la
personnalité du président de cette
commission qui s'appelle thomas skins et
monsieur thomas ce king qui est un
gouverneur du new jersey ans et que rien
de le dire j'ai un amis la famille bush
a dans sa biographie officielle
un point qui a totalement été effacés
officiellement c'est à dire on décrit en
effet toutes les activités caritatives
auxquelles s'est livrée mais on ne met
un point important c'est qu'il est le
directeur est le principal actionnaire
d'un groupe pétrolier qui s'appelle
amerada hess et ce groupe pétrolier à
meyrannes as a passé des accords mais
vraiment extrêmement important avec une
compagnie saoudienne pétrolière aussi
qui s'appelle delta oil et qui est
dirigé par des membres de la famille
royale saoudienne et cette compagnie
commune donc à opérer massivement dans
les régions comme la mersey chef de la
commission d'enquêté le chef de la
commission d'enquêté la chose très
intéressante c'est que parmi
effectivement ses associés dans ce
groupe pétrolier il y a deux personnes
qui sont deux saoudiens à banquer
saoudien et un autre à nos milliardaires
saoudiens des membres aussi proche de la
famille royale et qui sont tous deux
inculpés par les familles aujourd'hui
par des familles des victimes c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui
monsieur donc thomas skin enquête sur un
tragédie dont soi-disant les financiers
seraient en effet deux de ses anciens
associés
mais ça n'a pas conduit du tout à
démissionner c'est une situation
incroyable il ya un truc incroyable
aussi c'est que les américains avaient
prévu que le world trade center puisse
être attaqué et le matin du 11 septembre
il y avait la défense aérienne qui
étaient en alerte depuis 6h du matin
tiens c'est pas un truc contrairement à
ce que nous a expliqué qu'il les a
surpris il pensait que ça pouvait
arriver et il avait même l'idée que ça
arrive ce jour là oui il y avait deux
exercices d'alert ce matin le 11
septembre au matin il y avait d'abord le
norad qui est chargé de surveiller
l'espace aérien de protéger l'espace
aérien américain qui était un état d'
alerte maximum les avions étaient déjà
effectuant les chasseurs étaient déjà
effectivement encore l'air est alors la
chose plus troublante c'est que lorsque
les attentats ont été effectivement donc
connu donc on a lancé des avions donc
pour
à la recherche et surtout donc
pour essayer de récupérer donc les
appareils de ligne ne vous a fait
décoller de bases extrêmement éloignés
on aurait pu les faire décoller à côté
de washington ou à côté de new york où
il y avait des bases aériennes qui était
lui aussi en état d' alerte ou les
avions auraient pu intercepter
immédiatement les avions de ligne ça
pète elle car vous allez partir de très
loin et surtout il a fait voler à des
vitesses extrêmement réduite la source
très troublante c'est que ses avions de
chasse capable de voler à 2000 à l'heure
volet exactement à la vitesse des boeing
qu'ils étaient censés rattraper son
effet qu'est ce que vous voulez
démontrer mais je ne veux rien démontré
mot fait j'ai région du frioul nature
qui adhèreront qu'ils ont laissé deux
boeing entrer dans des tours plutôt que
de les intercepter alors qu'il pouvait
le faire ça si vous êtes en train de
dire qu'il y a eu des transactions
faites le dise ces transactions ne sont
pas toutes
anonyme on doit pouvoir remonter
d'étrangers leur côté du site vous avez
le moindre numéro je vous encourage à le
faire et si tout ce que vous avez dans
votre livre dans votre enquête fait je
vous encourage à passer le livre très
rapidement à john kerry qui le fera
savoir dans les dix jours à l'amérique
entière pour qu'enfin ce mec s'en aille
bouge pas ce qu'il va être réélu là mais
aussi lui absolument le faire passer je
vais vous dire non mais je vous dirais
lieu le film tire effectivement de mes
livres précédents et circulent sur des
sites qui rit maintenant et le matin du
11 septembre le matin du 11 septembre
comme disait était en état d' alerte
maximum et d'une part et il y avait
aussi un autre exercice d' alerte qui
était très troublant c'est à dire l'
agence de renseignement américaine la
plus la plus secrète chapelle le nro et
qui contrôle tous les satellites espions
américains à travers le monde avait
prévu un exercice d' alerte qui
prévoyait justement donc un attentat un
avion utilisés comme cibles volantes et
s'écrasant sur le siège de cette agence
est la chose la plus étonnante encore
c'est que le pentagone avait lui aussi
prévu plusieurs exercices dallaire de ce
genre et il y avait parmi les experts
qui travaillaient sur ce programme il y
avait un homme qui s'appelle jim bunning
am c'était un ancien pilote de la navy
et quand il avait quitté année ville
avait continué à travailler comme expert
pour le pentagone
et tout en travaillant comme expert pour
lui patagonie était commandant de bord à
american airlines et vous savez où il
était le matin du 11 septembre
il était à bord ou thé aux commandes du
vol american airlines 77 qui s'est
écrasé sur le pentagone
alors celui là il paraît qu'il n'a pas
existé alors entre deux fous parce qu'il
ya d'autres choses vous confirmer par
exemple qu'après le 11-septembre le ciel
américain était interdit évidemment au
vol non militaires disant mais pas aux
membres de la famille ben laden il ya
140 personnes famille ben laden vous
confirmer parce que ça on l'a dit un peu
et vous confirmez oui bien sûr il ya 140
personnes et de la famille royale
saoudienne qui ont pu quitter les états
unis malgré la fermeture du ciel oui
mais il ya un autre fait troublant parce
parmi les 140 personnes qu'on qu'on a
fait partir il y avait un personnage un
membre de la famille royale saoudienne
qui était le fils du prince salman le
prince salman est un des frères du roi
d'arabie saoudite et ce fils du prince
salman qui s'appelle prince fahd des
soul man etc et qui est des deux
responsables du plus grand groupe de
presse saoudiens et était à lexington
dans le kentucky où il était en train
d'acheter parce qu'ils avaient des
écuries de courses en train d'acheter
plusieurs chevaux donc il est reparti en
arabie saoudite et quelques mois plus
tard les américains ont arrêté donc un
des principaux adjoints de bin laden qui
s'appelle zoubaydah et la chose est
assez étonnante et ce sous bada été
arrêté au pakistan
les américains donc l'ont interrogé
longuement et ensuite de transférer sur
une base américaine
donc en afghanistan et là ils ont
maquillé la base américaine de façon à
ce que l'homme ait l'impression de se
retrouver effectivement dans une prison
saoudienne
il y avait deux deux hommes des forces
spéciales américaines dont deux arabes
américains qui étaient chargés de
l'interroger avec des uniformes saoudien
est plutôt qu'être paniqués ils auraient
dû être panique à lille se retrouve en
arabie saoudite
il a vraiment mais exulter et il s'est
penché vers les deux hommes hilare a dit
écoutez il a redonné de numéroter sony
dit écoute et appeler immédiatement on
vous dira ce qu'il faut faire et là
évidemment des américains ont vérifié et
les deux numéros de téléphone étaient
les numéros de téléphone de ce fameux
prince le prince une soul man et c'est
bon et sur le coup les américains n'y
croit pas à vraiment se disent en effet
non c'est une des informations et on
revient avec ce fameux responsable d'al
qaïda et on lui dit tu sais tu risque
gros parce que j'en ai fait donc accusé
un membre de la famille royale
saoudienne
tu vas avoir été tranchée souterraine où
tu dis mais non attendez vous n'a rien
compris et pendant dix minutes pendant
10 minutes
il va se livrer une confession qui va
essayer américain mais stupéfait c'est
heidi écouter n'y a pas seulement lui et
cite les noms de trois autres princes et
lille étaient au courant ils ont financé
une partie des attentats il savait pas
quand il aurait lieu ils savaient pas où
ils auraient lieu simplement sa seule
chose et il ajoute à 5e n'ont eux qui
est le responsable qui le nom du
responsable de de l'armée de l'air
pakistanaise le maréchal mire et la
chose tout à fait étonnante c'est que
personne n'est évidemment à washington
de protest n'adresse la moindre
protestation donc aux saoudiens et
curieusement trois mois plus tard fameux
prince fans meurt d'une crise cardiaque
absolument expliqué 43 ans immédiatement
après le lendemain donc son cousin qui
était aussi impliqué donc se rendait à
ses obsèques sur la route entre djeddah
et riyadh accident de voiture mortel et
le troisième cerise sur le gâteau tout
de même le troisième prince donc
impliquer compromis meurt vous savez de
quoi à 70km de ryad
il meurt de soif dans le désert
communiqué officiel et quant au dernier
donc effectivement les marches admire le
responsable pakistanais
son avion explosera en plein vol
expliqué il n'y aura jamais d'enquêté
officielle je sais ce que c'est c'est le
scénario de la saison 4 de 24 heures qui
passent sur quel public par exemple
qu'il serait possible que des cons
saoudien possède des entreprises je
dirais d'informatique d'entreprise
technologique américaine qui sont en
liaison avec la cia et le fbi a espère
qu'en fait il serait à l'intérieur du
truc c'est une réalité est dure tout ce
qui est dans le livre totalement étayé
il ya le cas d'un milliardaire saoudien
qui s'appelle le monsieur al qadi qui
est aujourd'hui un homme classé sur la
liste des 39 financier du terrorisme
donc international et monsieur al qadi
qui est donc un homme qui se livre non
seulement au commerce de diamants et
d'or qui sont en effet il faut bien le
dire les deux man l'essentiel oui
d'al-qaïda possède une société de haute
technologie qui s'appelle pitt est qu
installer donc logiquement donc dans le
massachusetts et qui a comme principaux
clients les principales agences de
renseignement américaines c'est à dire
le fbi heil seulement voilà le fbi
travaille sur de l'informatique sur des
souliers logiciel de madras et yann le
saoudien voilà qui leur vendent le matos
c'est pas grave mais c est ce qu ils ont
aussi quand ils le revendent bien sûr
les lauriers garder un double des clés
bah oui c'est ce que dit eric lange il
ya un truc énorme et là effectivement
c'est très excusez moi mais c'est très
thierry meyssan là quand même à vous dit
et si les services secrets israéliens
avaient été au courant et s'ils avaient
laissé faire parce que ça a aidé leur
cause
je dis simplement et c'est un fait avéré
qu'il y avait en effet 60 israéliens qui
étaient logés comme on dit en terme de
de métier juste à proximité donc des
terroristes du 11 septembre où théo
risotto dans plusieurs endroits la
floride aux endroits où les soi disant
terroristes étaient censés en effet
s'entraîner et la chose très troublante
mais c'est que le ce la cia le fbi a ils
les ont arrêtés les ont longuement
interrogés ont eu la preuve en effet
qu'il s'agissait d'agents du mossad et
la chose tout à fait étonnante là aussi
c'est qu'il y à l'épisode veut dire et
qui a été repris dans toute la presse
israélienne a juste moment où les tours
s'effondrent et ça c'est quand même très
très tout à fait étonnant ou autour ces
fronts il ya une femme qui doit prendre
garde et de spectacles de cette tragédie
et qui voit trois jeunes hommes qui sont
en train de sauter de joie
assis sur les toits nahman blanc bon
elle avertit la police devant évidemment
leur attitude extrêmement suspecte est
en effet la police les arrête et ils
sont quatre à l'intérieur et on découvre
qu'ils sont israéliens et l'un d'eux dit
d'ailleurs écouter nous sommes pas votre
problème
votre problème vos problèmes sont nos
problèmes et vous de vos problèmes sont
les palestiniens la cia et les services
de contre-espionnage donc les interroge
on les met en prison etc et on
s'aperçoit que ce sont des agents du
mossad travaillant sous couverture pour
une société qui s'appelle urban moving
et qui nous étaient chargés de
surveiller les islamistes radicaux pour
moi et quand ils reviendront donc sur en
israël la presse la presse israélienne
ne sera la première à s'indigner de leur
comportement en disant qu'ils ont eu un
comportement absolument choquant car on
retrouvera dans le vin des photos d'eux
l'une d'elle notamment où on voit comme
dans un concert d'ailleurs de rock de
pop
l'un d'eux avec les tours en train de
s'effondrer au fond en train d'allumer
donc à briquet voilà vous pensez que le
mossad était au courant de l'attentât du
world trade center
je nie pas que ça a été au cours de
votre santé les alliés d il ya un moment
faut se mouiller parce que quand on dit
tout à la fin faut dire non gel intime
conviction sur événement pas non non mon
intime conviction et des israéliens
probablement d'ailleurs il ya un journal
je cite un journal juif respecter new
york il s'appelle forward et qui dit
qu'en effet donc on savait que ces gens
donc les quatre les quatre jeunes
israéliens arrêtés étaient des agents
travaillant pour le mossad bien sûr
c'est une chose qui tout à fait reconnu
mais vous savez ce que je raconte aussi
c'est que israël se livre à des
activités d'espionnage aux états unis
non non je raconte dans le livre et à
plusieurs reprises ont espionné la
maison blanche rhin et au moment où ils
ont effectué les branchements et chaque
fois qu'un président américain notamment
le dernier en date clinton décroché son
téléphone
il y avait effectivement donc un
transfert de la communication sur tel
aviv ou jérusalem en inde et nous alors
vous confirmez ce qui était donnée
jusqu'ici comme une grosse intox
c'est l'histoire des messages
avertissant les employés vous parlez de
la société odigo c'est vrai ça bien sûr
c'est vrai ça s'est passé comment ça
s'est passé très simplement aux 10 go
est une société de serveurs
installé en israël avec donc un certain
nombre en effet donc des succursales aux
états unis et deux agents de fans de
deux responsables de haut diego ont reçu
un message
deux heures avant les faits donc la
suite des tours à la teneur de messages
effectivement n'est pas très clair mais
c'était un message avertissant en effet
de l'imminent soi-disant des attentats
et les responsables de la coupe de la
firme aux digues aux lois immédiatement
transféré donc aux responsables
israéliens et non transférer également
haut responsable américain
vous avez une chose très intéressante
dans l'histoire du grand emprunt de 100
ter et dans l'effondrement du contrat de
santerre vous avez vous parlé tout à
l'heure c'est que on a découvert
beaucoup mieux parce que vous disiez
trou il faut trouver des traces on va
trouver des traces et ça qui est tout à
fait étonnant c'est à dire que au fond
là l'effondrement des tours de votre
attente et a été le crime parfait
j'ai évidemment non seulement en raison
du nombre de victimes mais pour ce qui
concerne les transactions financières
car on avait constaté qu'il y avait à un
niveau extrêmement élevé de transactions
qui s'opérait au moment juste avant
l'attaqué contre les tours et au
moment-même d'ailleurs où les tours
étaient en train de brûler c'est être
des ordinateurs fonctionner les
transactions financières était beaucoup
plus élevé que la moyenne
à l'intérieur de votre inventaire bien
sûr moment même et immédiatement
immédiatement après la chute
immédiatement après la chute des tours
d'octobre un certain nombre de
compagnies qui sont les sociétés de
crédit des sociétés financières se sont
réunis en poule pour essayer en effet
donc d'exhumer un certain nombre de
disques durs 2 mais ces deux de ses
ordinateurs et ils ont confié
effectivement donc l'analyse de ces
disques durs à une société allemande qui
sape la société convard donc et qui est
un procédé de systèmes par laser qui
permet en effet de relire en effet sur
des disques de l'unedic ce que très très
endommagée et le responsable de cette
fille en convard a fait un aveu un cela
veut il a dit ce qui vraiment ce qui
apparaît à la lecture est la découverte
de ces informations c'est un gigantesque
des initiés et il a dit je pense qu'on
sera effectivement qui sont les
responsables et le fbi a bloqué les
choses vraiment et parce que la société
a accepté de collaborer avec eux et à
partir de là tout a été complètement
c'est l'omerta c'est la loi du silence
autour du 11 septembre
c'est ça qui est tout à fait différent
voilà la dernière chose c'est bourré de
scoop son bouquin c'est vraiment
incroyable
dernière chose la traduction des
cassettes de ben laden dans lesquelles
ils revendiquent les attentats contre le
world trade center et vous dit que
finalement la traduction quand on fait
les américains n'est pas exact il y eu
énormément de gaza du ciel ou qatar al
jazira justement possédant mode est
lapidé casse est donc de 2 bin laden il
ya une cassette qui est très troublante
parce que en effet les américains disent
avoir trouvé à djalalabad donc la ville
d'afghanistan où je suis années et les
afghans les responsables quand j'ai vu
disent qu'on n'a jamais trouvé de
cassettes labo la date que donnent les
américains n'est pas la bonne
et ensuite cette cassette est resté
pendant deux mois donc entre les mains
donc des responsables américains et
ensuite bush a décidé au mois de
décembre donc fin décembre de la
diffuser et simplement lorsqu'on regarde
donc la casse est originale en arabe est
la traduction qui a été fait ensuite on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya des ajouts qui a des
partis dans la partie originale rap
complètement inaudible qui ont été donc
transformé sur lesquels on a apporté au
traitement un certain nombre de deux
mots d'éléments de phrases et ses acquis
maiden a confirmé en effet donc la
responsabilité de ben laden mais ce qui
fait qu ensuite ben laden est allé
directement donné ses cassettes al
jazeera pourquoi vous riquez la
traduction que je pense qu'il a voulu
effectivement éviter on n'a qu'à
l'avenir les choses puissent lui
échapper en terme d'image oui comment
vous expliquer alors que ben laden les
revendique c'est non ces attentats non
non non mais nadal n'a jamais revendiqué
les attentats à laquelle justement on le
voit avec oui mais justement c'est celle
de nous parler c'est donc parler
seulement des trucs et celle là est
complètement retouchée je n'y a pas
truqué complètement retoucher les autres
cassette qui arrive après n'évoque pas
directement les attentats à chaque fois
bin laden dire les faits je suis heureux
en effet c'est un acte admirable sur des
martyrs extraordinaire mais huit même
personnellement non et août et au début
quand qu'il est qu'ils pensaient pas que
les deux tours allait s'effondrer oui
mais justement c'est cette la c7 cassel
un milieu et qu'est ce qu'on dit alors
justement il s'arrache à la trad
contrats traduisent normalement c'est
une assiette le beau gars quand vous
savez tout ça
écoutez moi je crois que c'est très
simple enfin je crois qu'il faut
enquêter c'est tout bravo eric alors et
vous étiez vous étiez sur le terrain on
va accueillir maintenant quelqu'un qui
était encore plus proche du terrain
c'est le sergent chef adam a
[Musique]
bonjour
bonjour le sergent chef adam à vous êtes
un soldat des forces spéciales
vous êtes un béret vert ah oui je suis
aussi membre de la garde nationale
alors on mai 2002 vous avez été envoyés
en afghanistan pour traquer les membres
d'al-qaida justement et vous êtes revenu
avec un livre coécrit avec le capitaine
alan hatch qui s'appelle se livre sur
les traces d'al qaïda
c'est publié chez alban édition voilà
alors c'est un témoignage de deux
membres des forces spéciales alors dit
votre arrivée en afghanistan
vous découvrez des problèmes de
logistique des problèmes de sécurité
alors vous dites qu a pas assez de
soldats ça c'est quelque chose de très
important dans votre livre
il ya qu'à l'état major où il ya un
nombre suffisant de militaires mais vous
dans l'action quotidienne
il ya très très peu de soldats par
rapport à ce qu'il a à faire
l'afghanistan c'est à peu près la taille
du texas
donc il ya des déserts des montagnes
très haute des déserts arides pas de
routes pas l'infrastructure exactement
d'une situation très difficile et à
l'époque quand j'étais sur place mais y
avait peut-être environ deux mille
hommes sur place sur le terrain en
dehors des camps militaires et donc donc
on était très peu c'est clair mais en
plus au niveau du quartier général il y
avait énormément de bureaucratie et à
tel point qu'il était difficile
d'obtenir des approbations pour tout
simplement sortir de la base et pour
aller sur le terrain justement à ce qui
est très étonnant aussi c'est que le
matériel moderne n'est pas utilisée par
exemple un moment vous réclamez des
hélicoptères et on vous dit qu'un appât
il ya plein d'hélicoptères tout neufs
comme ça qui sont sur un tarmac c'est
incroyable ça en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que quand on demandait du soutien
rien pour les quelque part on ne pouvait
pas aller en voiture est bien ce moment
là on nous répondait m'écouter ya pas
d'hélicoptère disponible mais ensuite
vous sortiez du bâtiment tout simplement
et vous regardiez que vous voyez que des
hélicoptères toute une série
d'hélicoptères des hélicoptères qu'on
aurait utilisé est donc ce qu'il fallait
qu'on fasse c'est qu'on n'utilise ce
doux pour disposer à savoir des camions
des 4 4 alors voilà déjà se pose la
question que pose son livre c'est à dire
est ce que tout ça c'est l'incompétence
de la main américaine
ou est-ce qu'au contraire il ya une
volonté de ne pas attraper des mecs
parce que bon puis surtout c'est
peut-être pas la vraie guerre là tout de
suite on va la faire parce qu'on est
obligé de passer par là est la vraie
guerre elle est plus c'est à dire avant
dix minutes alors le plus incroyable
dans votre bouquin c'est l'incapacité à
attraper les terroristes par exemple le
mollah osmani qu'est le numéro un des
militaires talibans il a été détenu
quinze jours à la base de kandahar après
que vous l'ayez à mener et et avant son
transfert vers une prison afghane et
ensuite il a acheté son évasion pour
cent cinquante mille dollars en liquide
et il est parti au pakistan la bon
certes c'était une source de frustration
extrême pour lui il faut bien dire en
fait nous on était habillé en portaient
des burqas et on devait se déplacer en
étaient déguisés en femmes afghanes
donc on a mis nos boss que envie et on a
fini par attraper ce type qui était un
type terrible qui était responsable de
la mort de biens des personnes et comme
je vous le disais donc une fois qu'on
attrape quelqu'un a bien bien évidemment
on le passe au grill on veut l'entendre
ensuite c'est fini mais après quand on a
entendu qu'ils avaient été relâchés il
ya un an qu'un afghan qui est venu nous
voir il vous est pas possible on n'a pas
relâché ce type c'est complètement
incroyable
c'est incroyable alors le mollah omar
c'est pareil c'est à dire qu'ils étaient
positionnés par satellite
vous dites on avait
son numéro de portable on avait sans le
numéro de sa toyota
on avait le nom de son chauffeur on
avait tout l'été complètement repérer et
aucune arme n est allé s'emparer de lui
nous a dit là où on pensait qu'il était
et s'il a réussi à survivre aussi
longtemps c'est tout simplement parce
qu'il se déplaçait rapidement ils
passaient jamais plus d'un jour ne
manquent pas et on nous a dit qu il
pensait qu'il savait la ville étaient
mes problèmes c'était que cet endroit
n'était pas accessible en voiture et
donc il a fallu qu'on rendre à la base
et qu'on demande des hélicoptères est
donc là comme je vous le disais les
hélicoptères étaient alignés
indisponible et donc ils ne nous ont
jamais dit non mais en fait il ne veut
jamais dit oui non plus pendant et ça a
duré plusieurs jours et puis voilà alors
la question qu'il se pose voilà encore
une fois simple cafouillage de l'armée
ou alors volonté d'attendre les
élections américaines pour arrêter le
mollah omar ben laden mais là on n'y aux
élections américaines
donc c'est pas ça je crois qu'on n'a
aucune envie d'attraper bin laden je
pense que on sait où il est on sait à
peu près où il est mais il est une telle
représentation de dire est symbolique de
la menace terroriste que la trappe
éprouveraient au fond on est en mesure
de juguler cette menace terroriste et je
crois que personne ne souhaite
ne serait ce que par exemple quand on
voit par exemple à tora bora
on a laissé partir je dire lorsqu'on a
lancé une attaque terrestre tora bora
donc en décembre 2001 on sait déjà
maintenant aussi laden était déjà parti
et on n'avait pas du tout fermé la
frontière et le pakistan
l'ate a pris un coup sur la tête là ce
soir oui et non parce que en fait on
imagine toujours le pire événement rend
compte qu'il faut multiplier par 1000 et
qu'on est encore en dessous de la vérité
enfin
le respect que je vous dois on nous dit
que vous avez complètement raison
tu vas se veut dire ce n'est jamais
apporté plus de preuves que ça tu nous
décrit un voyage écoutez moi je peux
vous dire c'est que si je savais où il
était planquée moi j'irai le chercher
ça ne fait aucun doute je pense qu'il
est encore en vie mais je pense qu'il
est quelque part au pakistan et je pense
que en fait le truc c'est qu'on n'a pas
envie de rentrer au pakistan ce bien
merci en tous les cas merci d'avoir été
avec nous merci à la mairie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'accueille karine ferri
et oui voilà vous êtes
j'attends de saintes non pas du tout ah
bon alors la chaîne survenue quand j'en
aurais quand même car il est la fille de
luc ferry donc non pas exactement mais
bon cette pente avec les gens pour les
gros bateaux qui vont en angleterre non
plus non pas du tout non non pas du tout
vous êtes karine ferri en fait voilà non
mais c'est pas mon vrai nom de famille
et c'est le nom de jeune fille de ma
grand mère italienne
je me demandais pourquoi gaccio vous
regardez comme ça karine ferri est connu
pour être l'élu poste jeu de steven le
bachelor deux cas pas vu le match ne
s'est pas sur m6 et et karine va faire
ses débuts à la télévision sur fun tv
mercredi prochain voilà voilà
alors on va commencer par le
commencement parce qu'effectivement je
vois pas en plus je ne le connais pas je
comprends si je sais ce que c'est de
bachelor ah je ne savais pas que bien
alors on commence donc le bachelor va le
principe vous le connaissez lionel c'est
un mec qui doit choisir parmi un certain
nombre de gonzesses celle qu'ils
préfèrent
alors nous on dit deux filles voilà
alors la première année olivier avait eu
le coup de foudre pour alexandra et la
deuxième année stéven a été incapable de
choisir entre candice et vous voilà est
la fin de l'émission il est reparti tout
seul
quelques jours après la fin du jeu
rebondissements effectivement stevan et
vous fait la une de télé loisirs
et vous dites on s'est rendu compte bah
oui on s'est rendu compte en rentrant à
paris qu'on étaient faits l'un pour
l'autre
je ne sais pas faire masser les normes
il ay la voilà voilà c'est évidemment
évidemment
n'avait pas choisi karine pendant le jeu
et qu'ils ont annoncé qu'ils étaient
ensemble
après le jeu tout le monde a crié au
coup de pub vous en attendez c'est pas
possible cette histoire est alors karine
a déclaré ceux qui n'y croient pas ceux
qui n'y croient pas un autre amour donc
à venir passer une nuit chez nous et moi
je suis d'accord
juste avant avec le journaliste là c'est
vraiment alors l'histoire dans
l'histoire c'est qu'en fait quand vous
êtes rentré après le jeu vous étiez
dites vous dans un piteux état
vous êtes enfermé seul chez vos parents
et bah oui mais vous avez un peu fripé
petit nouveau nom évidemment j'ai été
j'étais peiné forcément mais elle n'est
pas enfermée chez moi vous a dit hu
recommence à faire la gueule parce
qu'ils avaient une rupture juste avant
le bal store avait déjà une première
rupture dans les bottes mère maquerelle
vous avez vu faire la gueule
elle s'est dit ça va recommencer à faire
la gueule vous avez sur le dos toute la
journée bon je préférais quand vous
étiez dans le bachelor bon ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'une semaine plus tard
stevan a téléphoné et là effectivement
vous être vu et vous dites on s'est
revus dans des lieux fermés et dit elle
juste pour une nuit
[Musique]
c'est ma nouvelle musique érotique
allait bien baird léonard
[Musique]
et alors dans ces lieux fermés y avait
aussi
malgré tout malgré tout quand même télé
star parce que l'annoncé a été faite
dans télé loisirs télé star dit elle ne
correspond en rien à l'idéal qu'il
disait rechercher dans le bachelor
samalens j'écrivais ce tarif 10 elle a
21 ans
elle souhaite pas avoir d'enfant elle
aime pas new york
donc c'est en bizarre j'aimerais savoir
ce que le service secret israélien est
au courant de télé star télé star a
quand même déjà un peu la puce à
l'oreille télé star s'est dit c'est
bizarre un peu comme éric leurent
effectivement sur l'histoire du 11
septembre
et là c'est la bombe c'est la bombe télé
7 jours
une progression de télé 7 jours révèle
l'existence d'un second contrat entre
stéven et m6 pour faire semblant d'y
télé 7 jours d'être amoureux après la
fin de l'émission
dans le but de créer un nouveau
rebondissement voilà victime c'est vrai
que la fin la fin ne nous donne pas la
rose alors que dans le premier vous
donne donc c'est vrai que les
l'impression que marina ne suis pas je
m'intéresse voilà là j'en suis à
l'arrosage ensuite ai laissé deux jours
et sur le coup télé poche ils sont
largués télé
des loisirs télé star télé 7 jours télé
7 jours a découvert le cru tempête
marina parce qu'un jour il ya des
négociations sur les droits photo d'un
voyage à tahiti et les gens de télé 7
jours qui négocient pour avoir karine
estevan à tahiti s'aperçoivent qu'en
fait il ya un deuxième contrat ce qu'on
appelle la sphère du deuxième contrat
voilà en fait vous êtes le premier
couple payé pour faire semblant d'être
amoureux en dehors de l'émission jusque
là ils sont payés pour être amoureux
dans l'émission vous vous êtes les
premiers faux mais évidemment c'est faux
je vous invite à passer la soirée avec
lyon vous allez voir c'est véridique non
mais ça que vous désirez maison monsieur
n
tu nous as dit tout à l'heure au début
de l'émission que cela faisait quinze
jours que tu avais paniquer
là ça se voit
je dirais je te comprends un peu oui oui
la wii alors racontez nous moi je donne
la version de télé loisirs de télé star
télé 7 jours quelle est votre version à
vous vous aimez vraiment c'est sérieux
cette histoire on on est ensemble on
vient d'emménager ensemble qui porte la
culotte dans votre couple
à votre avis c'est vous ah bon pourquoi
j'ai pas parce que je vous vois comme ça
vous avez une forte femme qui porte le
string dans notre groupe à témoin c'est
moi qui fait le lit de ménage la
vaisselle on va dire c'est moi bien
c'est bien celle origines italiennes ça
c'est vrai c'est plus jusqu'à la samba
hockey qui a déjà trompé l'autre karine
écouté personne alors il ya une seconde
alors quoi qu'il en soit vous êtes
arrivé quand même à faire de la télé
c'était votre rêve non non ce n'était
pas un rêve parce que je pense que je ne
savais pas si j'avais le talent pur et
puis surtout ça s'improvise pas je pense
être animatrice et s'improvise pas donc
je travaille tous les jours j'ai eu
l'opportunité de faire quelque chose sur
fun tv j'ai accepté tout se passe très
bien
j'en suis ravi mais évidemment je débute
donc il ya encore beaucoup de travail
mais je pense qu'on va y arriver
on dirait un joueur de football et
l'important c'est les trois points
on dirait un joueur de foot à peu on
construit l'équipe trois points pour les
panières alors fenty vie donc mercredi
27 octobre à 17h10 l'émission s'appelle
sans choses interdites aux plus de 30
ans voilà le concept c'est quoi ces des
épreuves des défis les défis des défis
donc on a trois garçons trois filles qui
font des défis en fait on réalise un
petit peu ce que les gens ont fait un
sondage en a rue on essaie de savoir un
petit peu ce que ce que les gens avant
d'avoir 30 ans aimerait faire un vrai
réalisé limites du possible et on envoie
donc nos deux équipes les réaliser alors
pas comme ça c'est pas ça sera pas dans
l'émission exemple mais c'est une
déclaration d'amour à une star il ya eu
quoi d'autre perturber un terrain de
golf et sans polfer 40 30 ans quand dès
qu'on a dépassé 30 ans que non non non
non c'est vrai que le titre simplement
ça s'appelle sans chose interdite depuis
30 ans parce que on a on s'est dit bon
c'est vrai qu'à 30 ans on estime que la
personne doit être plus posée est ce que
c'est vrai nom c'est ce sont des a
priori mais toi tu t'es pas loin de toi
j'ai 12 ans t'as pas envie d'accoucher
là maintenant tout de suite erp aux
parents avec les services secrets
israéliens sont au courant que tu es
enceinte oui mais c'est moi qui les ai
appelés gym besoin qu'on parle de moi
bien alors qu'arrive vous savez qu'à la
télémaintenance qui se porte bien
surtout sur ses chaînes comme sat jeunes
du câble et du satellite c'est d'être
trash donc on va voir si vous êtes assez
trash pour faire de la télé on va faire
un trajet test alors 26 de karim quelle
est la pire insulte que vous connaissiez
[ __ ] de son père y avant que prend
d'ailleurs soin d'elle et de son père de
sa mère et de son père non j avais
jamais pensé je trouve ça beaucoup plus
réaliste que [ __ ] de sa mère est
presque poétique elle est bien alors
quels sont les drogues auxquels vous
n'avez pas encore touché où là il y en a
beaucoup
enfin je préfère être dire à la limite
quelle drogue
quelle drogue j'ai touché absorbé quoi
parce que tout chez moi aussi je peux
toucher évidemment nicotine nicotine
c'est la seule droit que vous ayez
presse dans votre vie vous avez arrêté
là non non pourquoi parce que parce que
ça me détend voilà donc non c'est mon
seul péché mignon on va dire parce que
j'ai besoin de toucher et crade
c'est quoi les pêcheurs a fait une bonne
pub pour les clubs parce que ça rend les
dents blanches alors karine combien sont
parfaites non mais t'es pas mal alors
car il convient de secours pouvez vous
rester sans vous l'avez aucun aucun est
ce que vous êtes déjà automutilée non
jamais non non pas trois heures dans ma
vie j'ai aucun problème psychologique en
tout cas à ma connaissance rien de la
partie pas de tatouage non combien les
rues de petits copains dans votre vie
des visées ou alors non non le dossier
dedans
voilà la forte fibre au tube franchement
tu vois un peu de fraîcheur tout de
suite à la main beaucoup ça beaucoup
combien son brame 67 marina pratiquement
vierge
bon bah il ya tous les robins quel est
le pire coup de [ __ ] que vous ayez
jamais fait un mec ou le tromper ah
ouais vous en avez trompés sur les sept
villages algériens ça excuse et non un
seul vous l'avez tromper un [ __ ] mais
l'entente n'ont pas longtemps avec son
nom suffit pas d'être très longtemps
quand même quelqu'un général kouassi
connaît par exemple des semaines bien
sûr non sa posture bien sûr est-ce que
vous avez déjà regardé un film porno à 2
oui avec stéven avec steven mais à deux
ça peut être une copine voilà est-ce que
vous avez déjà porter un slip en cuir
non jamais c'est marrant ça c'est pas
remporté à 20 ans ne s'est pas cherché
les animatrices
est ce que vous êtes j'appuie du sang
n'ont jamais non plus à vous buvez pas
de questions quand même temps c'est le
trash test voici que je vous ai pris
chez m6 ça parce que vous êtes très
basses baisse est-ce que vous allez
porter des menottes ailleurs que dans un
commissariat
non non et même pas dans le commissariat
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous avez déjà vu
vos parents faire l'amour non jamais je
faisais déjà baiser dans le lit de vos
parents n'ont jamais non non
qu'est ce que c'est
aujourd'hui les nier on va passer ces
horribles dans le monde en les séparant
interview trash c'est un trajet
alors on voit bien que c'est pas la
peine de le préciser est ce que vous
êtes déjà filmé en train de faire
l'amour non plus et j'ai juste d'ajouter
si karine franchement et thierry je
viens juste de recevoir mon premier
caméscope est ce que vous avez déjà
partagé un copain avec une copine
non jamais je n'en je suis trop
exclusive pour ça et un copain avec un
copain jamais non plus moi je te rends
ton numéro
[Musique]
maintenant va les laisser se coucher les
femmes allaient écrire quelques lignes
dans la main
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est quoi
[Applaudissements]
on va toucher on va la regarder dormir
et maintenant j'y vois si joe cocker
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir j'ai le coeur bonsoir
toi tu avais merci d'être avec nous au
jo la veille françois viaud en deux sets
on a gardé nos vols
c'est une telle hausse bonjour alors
pour tous ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas
joe cocker joe cocker c'est ça
[Musique]
aulas
miquel
[Musique]
ça aurait un choix
m
pour r
[Musique]
mon coeur
au nigeria
b la gauche
j'aime à rome
pas sûr dans l'air
[Musique]
là
n'oubliez jamais
[Musique]
on fait
voilà joe cocker jakab dans le sionisme
nous touchons minuit joe cocker est ce
que vous connaissez
orlando états unis oui papa pas la ville
de floride
un type qui s'appelle orlando non le
frère le frère de dalida
je ne connais pas you know pascal ce
blâme pas si nous continuons orlando
exige le clip
chaque fois qu'un chanteur vient dans
cette émission
orlando monsieur orlando exige le clip
voilà donc vous allez regarder votre
caméra plaisir lukacs aux caméras and
you just say un magnéto ch
magnéto c'est bravo
[Applaudissements]
petro
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
voilà extrait de joe cocker live
le best-of sur dvd mesdames messieurs
voilà à haikou halal le dvd je vous le
conseille une chanson qui me semble que
tu as oublié
ouais tout au début un alan a chanté un
truc c'est pas joe cocker ah oui
[Musique]
joker dites nous ce que vous pensez de
ce chanteur vraiment sérieusement
[Musique]
ouais 2,5 c'est une femme
et oui voilà alors en plus du dvd
joe cocker sort un nouvel album didier
l'ofs
[Musique]
m
et mes amis
mais brillamment
[Musique]
non
je sais
nous espérons mieux
[Musique]
gration
vers le chapitre 5 the do
amo a
tél
[Musique]
à
on m'a expliqué que faire
habib kane toulouges calcio
[Musique]
appliquée
toulouse cap shaw
waouh
[Musique]
chuck aule coeur le dernier album
s'appelle entame sa carrière
ma
bravo
alors ce qui est incroyable avec avec
vos joe cocker c'est que vous avez eu
énormément de succès et pourtant vous
n'êtes pas un performeur vous n'êtes pas
un showman géré quand vous êtes sur
scène vous courez pas dans tous les sens
comme mick jagger au rod stewart
vous êtes derrière votre micro oui c'est
tout à fait exact en fait j'utilise un
micro droit devant moi un croc fixe et
est donc je peux pas courir donc quand
j'étais plus jeune c'est vrai que
j'utilisais un micro portable quand je
tenais dans la main mais maintenant même
si j'ai une voix plutôt grave
j'ai l'impression d'être un petit peu
comme un chanteur d'opéra mais ça me
permet de faire passer mon message
ça c'est la première raison déjà c'est
pas showman et puis deuxièmement vous
n'avez fait que des reprises ya très peu
de chansons qui ont été écrites par vous
même parce que j'ai dit je ne sais pas
jouer d'un instrument dont quand j'ai
une mélodie dans la tête
elle s'en va tout de suite et finalement
vous avez fait votre succès sur des
reprises en lait en les améliorant d'une
certaine façon dans moi je ce que je
pensais que ce sont mes propres
interprétations il ya des gens qui font
des reprises depuis des années c'est
quelque chose de normal c'est tout à
fait naturel on a mis à chanter les
chansons des autres mais en fait les
gens n'aiment pas forcément un lien
aussi fort que moi avec ses chanteurs
donc moi j'essaye d'en ajouter une
petite touche de joe cocker à toutes mes
chansons mais les beatles par exemple
quand vous avez fait from my friends les
beatles vous avez envoyé un télégramme
de félicitations parce qu'il trouvait
que l'interprétation de joe cocker était
mieux que la leur j'adore bono ouais one
il l'a très bien
absolument alors joe cocker votre truc
en fait c'est votre voix
vous dites d'ailleurs c'est un c'est un
cadeau c'est ça c'est un don du ciel
cette voie non ça dépend de renault du
côté duquel vous placé par rapport à toi
mais au fil des ans il faut bien voir
que j'ai travaillé ma voix mais j'ai
essayé de maintenir mon patrimoine et
maintenant j'ai atteint l'âge et
fatidique de 60 ans est bon vous savez
il faut dire que je jamais pensé que
j'atteindrai cet âge là vous vous buvez
combien de verres de mazout par jour
pour avoir cette voie vous savez j'ai
arrêté de boire voilà trois ans non mais
quand je lisais les uns quand on chante
dans des bars etc
on reste sur beaucoup de fumée et c'est
vrai que sur vos paquets de cigarettes
ya marqué tu me dois tout non non ça
j'ai arrêté aussi j'ai arrêté de faire
les quelques années alors vous pouvez
plus d'alcool turc à coeur vous ne buvez
pas d'alcool depuis trois ans ce qui
fait que lorsque vous retournez dans
votre ville natale sheffield ville
minière du nord de l'angleterre
si le service public finalement vous
n'êtes pas content du tout parce que
d'abord ils sont tous jaloux de vous
parce que tous les mecs avec qui vous
buviez au peuple il ya des années vous
avez réussi pas eu et ensuite ils
continuent à boire et vous vous avez
arrêté ce qui fait que vous ne
retournais jamais dans cette ville de
sheffield
non c'est vrai que je rentre pas très
souvent à sheffield
vous avez raison thierry il ya un petit
peu d'amertume de du côté des musiciens
que j'ai connu quand j'étais plus jeune
qui n'ont pas réussi comme et donc
lorsque je rentre au pays
c'est un petit peu difficile de
m'identifier à eux la cigarette vous
l'avait arrêté après un voyage en
australie vous avez passé 15 heures dans
un avion vous êtes devenu fou il y a
parce que je sais pas si vous êtes déjà
allé en australie en avion mais c'est
vraiment long et donc 15 heures donc il
est bien possible de fumer donc vous
avez arrêté la drogue aussi john en y en
avait vous avez rencontré votre femme
pam à santa barbara la fin des années 70
c'est grâce à elle que vous avez
vous avez arrêté la drogue sans panne
vous seriez morts oui c'est vrai qu'elle
m'a beaucoup aidé à sortir de ces
moments difficiles
c'est difficile d'expliquer à qui que ce
soit vous savez lorsque vous tombez
vraiment dans le gouffre parce qu'il
faut bien voir que je chantais toujours
je ressens toujours mes tournées etc
mais il faut dire que j'avais perdu un
peu le ma passion alors aujourd'hui vous
habitez dans le colorado aux jo dans un
manoir anglais que vous avez fait
construire dans le dans le colorado
alors écoute bien la vie qu'il a
maintenant quand même vous élever des
vaches vous élever des chevaux de course
vous pêcher à la mouche et vous fait des
balades avec votre chien
c'est exactement ça ouais c'est pas
casse couilles ça va c'est en fait c'est
bizarre parce que quand je reviens en
tournée bien tout de suite je passe en
mode nuit
donc je reste éveillé jusqu'à 3 heures
du matin mais quand je retourne au
colorado et bien tout de suite je passe
en mode jour et à ce moment là je me
lève le matin à 6h30 et puis je vais me
balader en forêt et j'adore ça ça me
plaît beaucoup
en fait c'est simplement un contraste
vraiment saisissant est intéressant pour
moi c'est pas très rock'n'roll
je sais je sais bien alors ça vous
change quand même de woodstock
cinq cent mille personnes tu sais ça car
une fois tu vas pas connu ça toi
woodstock il a chanté devant 500 mille
personnes c'était absolument c'est pas
d'air c'est pas très agréable c'est pas
le meilleur concert de votre vie
j'imagine mans au delà de 50 mille
personnes vous savez on est dans une
chaude un petit peu à part c'est un
petit peu comme un jeu pas assez c'est
un petit peu ailleurs on sait pas qui
nous écoutent vraiment sais pas si les
gens nous écoutent et donc il est
vraiment difficile d'expliquer ce qu'on
ressent mais en fait c'est qu'il ya un
problème et un niveau de conscience en
fait il est difficile d'avoir le même
niveau de conscience que les gens qui
sont présents
la salle est donc ce show qu'on a fait
j'ai mis ce que j'aime bien c'est faire
des shows où l'on me voit vraiment on
voit vraiment les gens ça c'est bien des
chanteurs en france ils font ça continue
dans toute leur vie alors à woodstock ce
qui a fait merveille
ce sont vos hurlements vos
gesticulations qui était très inattendu
pour l'époque
et là quand vous êtes passés dans le ed
sullivan show qui a été la grosse
émission c'était drucker quoi quand vous
êtes passés dans cette émission il y
avait des danseuses qui se mettait
devant les caméras pour repos parce que
les producteurs voulaient pas qu'on vous
voit en fait il voulait pas que les
américains vous vois dieu même offert
quelques années auparavant
elvis il faut pas oublier ça et donc
quand il nage faisais mes petits petits
frustration le fait que je puisse pas
jouer le piano le fait que je voulais
même des choses mais en fait j'ai pas
vraiment conscient que je fais
d'ailleurs quand je le fais mais bon moi
je faisais j'étais plus démonstratif à
l'époque je faisais un petit peu peur
aux gens et donc quand ils ont commencé
à me voir faire tout ça et il se
souvient il ya des spasmes ce type ça va
pas donc ils ont mis des idées des
filles devant moi en espérant que je
serai cacher est ce que le rock'n'roll
est mort jo
le vrai r'n'b je pense que ça m'a jamais
mourir parce que ça c'est ça pose les
jalons de toute la musique que nous
connaissons pour le bac 8
alors on va voir ce qui est mort et ce
qui est pas mort on va faire l'interview
c'est mort alors joe cocker est ce que
les cheveux longs c'est mort c'est
vraiment la mauvaise personne à qui vous
posez la question lorsque je vois ce qui
se fait et font toujours qu'on a des
cheveux vous savez mais bon est-ce que c
des branches et oui peut-être est-ce que
la libération sexuelle c'est mort non je
ne prends pas je ne crois pas je pense
que les choses vont un petit peu évolué
depuis mon époque
c est ce que les tournée en bus à
travers les états unis
ces morts tournée prévue l'année
prochaine aux etats-unis et un retourné
il ya un film qui a été fait sur joe
cocker et leon russell qui s'appelle mad
dog and englishmen sur une tournée qui
l'a fait aux états unis dans les années
70 et tu les vois il ya chez pu y
apprendre musiciens il ya les femmes les
enfants les chiens ceci est
extraordinaire c'est un film sorti en
dvd d'ailleurs mad dog and rich man est
ce que les concerts sous la pluie avec
des milliers de fans sous acide
ces morts savez quand on a fait tout ce
stock ce qui était un petit peu bizarre
celle que c'était le seul type qui avait
pas pris de l'acide et donc il avait
oublié d'en mettre d'un jus d'orange
est-ce que les long solo à la guitare
gibson c'est mort je vois pas trop les
les guitaristes et faire ça à 28 en fait
je sais pas si c'est vraiment ce que je
préfère d'ailleurs c'est pas vraiment
jimi hendrix est ce que jouer de la
guitare avec les dents c'est mort il n'y
a pas beaucoup de gens qui arrivent à le
faire comme hendrix de toute façon avec
les dents bien est ce que les filles
dans votre lit après les concerts c'est
mort voilà mon dieu ça fait un moment
est ce que votre femme dans votre lit
après un concert c'est mort alors elle
est en 1/2 pour l'instant avec une amie
et donc elle ne travaillerais ne voyage
pas tant que ça avec moi mais c'est
dommage d'ailleurs est ce que john
lennon c'est mort ce qui me rassure
c'est qu'ils ont pas laisser sortir ce
type ils n'ont pas relâché parce que je
pense que quelqu'un se serait ou non
john lennon ne sera jamais ça c'est sûr
jamais mon beaucoup d'inspiration
est-ce que ce paul mccartney c'est mort
toujours été un petit peu morne
c'est vrai je l'adoré mais il faut bien
voir qu'il est toujours un petit peu
trop carré j'ai préféré c'est vrai
est-ce que sex drug and more garmin
bon si j'avais 25 ans j'aurais peut-être
un avis différent mais mais pour moi oui
ils sont enfin je sais pas quelque chose
qui marche encore pour certains en tout
cas au goût de certains
jean nouvel album s'appelle
à
[Musique]
le filet des deux
thank you very much merci beaucoup john
kerry merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très en forme très en forme bien c'est
que pour avoir une bois pareil continuer
à boire à flins ça et rien du tout
maintenant qu'il est parti on peut dire
que c'est de la merde
et maintenant
je suis
chacun et philippe val
alors fini balcon à jeumont plein je
vous plains parce qu'être le patron de
charlie hebdo venir dans une émission de
télé ce qui est très rare pour vous et
vous retrouver assis à côté d'une
vedette de la téléréalité franchement je
vous plains on se connaît pas d'ailleurs
j'ai jamais vu mais très joli voilà on
peut être patron de charlie hebdo et
être néanmoins un homme apparemment et
jean-marie oui alors vous avez déclaré à
la télévision il faut être un bon client
comme ils disent et je ne sais pas si je
suis un bon client
pourquoi parce qu'on ne sait pas à
l'avancé on sait jamais ces choses là si
ça dépend du climat dans lequel on est
dépendant tas de trucs comme ça c'est un
bon client et puis être un bon client
dans une interview c'est pas forcément
écrire des bons lisa c'est vrai il ya
des biens il ya beaucoup de bons clients
qui sont de mauvais écrivain il ya des
gens comme modiano ou sagan qui sont
incapables de s'exprimer à la télévision
et qui clôt diallo est un bon écrivain
dans cette journaliste rédacteur en chef
de charlie hebdo chroniqueur sur france
inter et là vous venez pour un livre et
un disque alors le livre s'appelle bons
baisers de ben laden
or ce sont des chroniques qui sont
publiés chez le cherche midi
france inter qui sont issus de charivari
votre chronique sur france inter ou de
charlie hebdo voilà alors chaque
chapitre est bien rangé
chaque chapitre est un thème le premier
chapitre c'est le terrorisme on a
beaucoup parlé tout à l'heure avec eric
laurent vous observer les réactions 11
septembre
et finalement vous découvrez que pour
beaucoup de gens sur la planète ben
laden est apparu comme un comme un
justicier qui venge le sud contre le
nord
opulent et finalement ces phrases les
américains l'ont bien cherché dans le
cul l'amérique et vous dit que tout ça à
éviter quand même de voir l'horrible
réalité ça devient de plus en plus
difficile quand on
on critique même l'islamisme pourtant
c'est pas très sympathique de pas passer
pour par exemple aux américains parce
qu'on est dans un monde binaire un monde
où tout est facile simple oui ou non
mais c'est pas oui et non voilà on peut
ne pas aimer la politique de bush et et
détesté ben laden c'est le front
national du tiers-monde ben laden pas
mal alors le deuxième chapitre donc est
consacrée aux us alors vous dit en
parlant de bush ya rien de pire que les
noceurs les fumeurs les baiseurs les
buveurs les [ __ ] des truands repenti
dire qu'en fait vous pensez vous dit que
finalement il pense que la façon dont
ils sont sortis de leur si rose doit
devenir un mode de vie universelle c'est
pas mal ça ouais c c'est comme ça les
gens qui ont arrêté de prendre le
plaisir ou comme il vient ils veulent
que plus personne ne jouissent en
général parce que voilà il voudrait
partager leurs ennuis avec tous et
michael sharks est une [ __ ] repenti qui
a fait fermer les bucks ont alors
troisième chapitre sur la religion c est
ce que l'homme a recours à la religion
parce qu'il va mal ou est-ce qu'il va
mal parce qu'il a recours à la religion
[Rires]
carrière
je trouve que bien souvent moi je suis
athée je suis pas mais bien souvent je
trouve qu on se réfugie dans la religion
et on passe même à côté de certaines
choses
oui vous dit l'homme a recours à la
religion parce qu'il va mal mais vous
n'approuvez pas exactement j'ai des
exemples auprès de moi et chaufferie
sais pas c'est pas nous c'est pas les
critères je pense que c'est d'abord
c'est rond ni religieuse avec le coeur a
obligé de faire des démos comment dire
oui mais bon de toute annonce qu'est ce
qui se passe autour des tours de voiture
je suis chanceux je vous signale que
c'est gaccio ils vous regardent comme le
ravi de la crèche alors que normalement
il aurait dû nous balancer 3,20 m c'est
vrai que c'est rationnel ne peut pas
diriger le monde à la maison
enfin serge édito compens avant de faire
des top si vous regardez donc
probablement voilà exactement c'est
aussi j'en parlerai à la cafet moi je
suis d'accord
bientôt il ya une phase de philippe
valcq que j'aime bien c'est d'après la
fameuse phrase de malraux le 21e siècle
sera spirituel ou ne sera pas et vous
vous dites
le xxième siècle sera laïque où ce sera
une boucherie en gros en tous les cas
ils ont déjà commencé la boucherie de
détail en irak
ouais ça vous dit les grecs qui divisait
dieu pour pouvoir régner sur lui par
exemple il m'était dieu sur le linge qui
était un monde
si on pouvait y aller à pied par beau
temps un sans problème pour aller
vérifier qu'ils y étaient ou qu'ils
n'étaient pas donc il n'y allait pas
parce que ça ils s'en foutent et un peu
d'avoir des dieux qui était à la fois
bon et mauvais très humain - crochet
l'humain de dieu et le fait de créer le
monothéisme et de mettre le bien d'un
côté le mal de l'autre ça fout un bordel
y nuit parce que là on est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça il y avait des demi
dieux si j'aimais bien les demi-dieux
dollon au japon pas alors chapitre 4
donc le chapitre iv sur leurs racines
tariq ramadan vous vous vous critiquez
vous avez l'air du temps alter
mondialiste oui tariq ramadan a été
invité à un forum social européen
grandes réunions altermondialistes je
pense que c'est une connerie ou qu'il a
rien à faire là dedans que lorsque c'est
quelqu'un qui est vraisembablement
d'autant plus dangereux qu'il est qu'il
est beau qu'il a du charme
il est intelligent et qui pense pas du
tout que l'église doivent être séparée
de l'état ça c'est un problème s'il
n'était pas avec le même discours est ce
que tu aurais tant d'inquiétude alors
rien à [ __ ] des questions vous parlez
de la corse alors vous dites que c'est
marrant parce qu'encore sont écrits par
exemple terracol sahara biffera
c'est-à-dire terre corse les arabes
dehors vous dit finalement la basse est
considérée comme un symbole de la
vitalité de la culture locale en france
quelques rares et ça ça serait un infâme
fasciste la seule explication que vous
trouvez finalement c'est que beaucoup de
journalistes intellectuels dans des
villes à la ba oui ce qui évite qu'on
dramatise ça oui je pense que c'est en
partie vrai je connais des gens qui ont
des villas là bas et qui disent le plus
grand bien des nationalistes et de la
mêmes des polyphonies corses alors que
ce soit
punition les polyphonies corses et
pourtant j'ai pas de villas là bas mais
j'étais obligé d'arrêter parce que je
pouvais plus sortir dans la rue
tutoiement que de nommer la corse est
exactement comme une maison de campagne
qu'on a en france
on y va quinze jours par an le reste de
l'année ça fait chier ça coûte cher
c'est un bon c'est le truc qui me
m'obsède mois la corse je m'en fous ce
qui est terrible en corse et dès qu'on
arrive il faut être du côté des
nationalistes un peu des mafieux quoi si
on veut être acceptée démago voilà ce
fait rêver cg blade desmazels référé
mais ça n'empêche pas qu'il ya des
corses extraordinaire réalité je mets
une généralité sur l'île se veut pas
dire que tous les corps se sont comme ça
la majorité des corses subissent ça avec
avec beaucoup de tristesse d'accord j'en
connais plein aussi et il préférerait
pas être pris pour des cons dans le
reste du monde à cause des 10 % qui
pensent avec leurs racines leur pensée
avec leur tête les parties avec des
racines c'est des légumes alors on en
arrive à la télé justement la
téléréalité ce que vous dites c'est vrai
que les gens ils vont plus voter aux
élections ils votent que pour la star ac
et en plus ils payent pour voter oui
c'est vrai j'avais pas pensé à ça c'est
incroyable c'est étonnant pourtant c'est
embêtant quand on est malade et qu'on va
à l'hôpital et qu'on est mal soigné s'il
n'y a pas assez de fric pour les
hôpitaux vaudrait mieux voter pour un
gouvernement qui dotent les hôpitaux que
de voter pour la star ac et d'art et on
risque plus d'en sortir vivant des
hôpitaux que de la star qui a des goûts
vite il y a un truc c'est que les
patrons de tf1 puis d'emera jamais voté
la star ac non bah ils savent quoi faire
de leurs fruits qui font autre chose il
ya un dernier chapitre consacré au
moyen-orient alors vous dites jérusalem
victimes de dieu et vous dites
finalement ce dieu bon le mec a dit à la
femme tu accouchera dans la douleur un
dieu qui n'avait pas prévu la péridurale
c'est quand même un connard donc si dieu
fait des erreurs dieu n'existe pas dans
tous les cas il est pas celui qu'on
croit
sinon il n'aurait pas pu dire ça un
homme a pu dire ça jérusalem c'est une
belle ville c'est une des villes les
plus belles qui soit quand on arrive là
par par la route de jéricho tu prend
part ou quand tu arrives toi parce que
moi je passe part de sa grande amie lori
par le bas avec cette ville assure
blanche sur la colline qui arrivent en
bus temps est venu de côté c'est à chier
mais tant qu'on touchera pas à dieu ce
sera la guerre oui il va falloir en
parler et fera part qu'ils en parlent
entre eux ça remet ça voilà c'est la
séparation de l'église et de l'état
c'est falloir que tout le monde en passe
un jour par là l'idée de philippe val
c'est de faire rentrer israël la
palestine dans l'europe c'est vrai
qu'israël ils sont déjà dans
l'eurovision oui et dans le championnat
d'europe de football s'est pas turquie
aussi la turquie s'est d'ailleurs c'est
vrai absolument la palestine bon mais en
la palestine aussi ce serait pas mal le
jour où c'est un état une parce que pour
pouvoir rentrer dans l'europe faut faire
la paix faut que les hommes et les
femmes et des droits égaux fin des tas
de choses plutôt sympathique quand même
on pourrait le faire on a bien fait
rentrer la pologne
voilà philippe rapp ça s'appelle bons
baisers de ben laden s'était dit
le cherche-midi france inter
[Applaudissements]
alors ça c'est le livre il ya le disque
publié chez chants du monde harmonia
mundi alors voilà je m'appelle
bernadette pourquoi ça s'appelle
bernadette non c'est une des chansons
qui s'appelle bernadette dans la dette
c'est une chanson d'amour pour une
poudre une femme qui tu peux pas avec
qui ça peut pas aller avec moi parce
qu'elle est déjà mariée elle est déjà
marié avec un type qui
qui voyagent beaucoup métier quand même
souvent la maison
tu es
été formulée
du
il dit
joe cocker maison de toi et moi et on
du fidèle alors c'est schirrhein avait
su voir sous l'eau serait roma me la
gazelle tremblant d'avis de deux carrés
[Musique]
derrière des résumés cher c'est dû aux
yeux noirs le fils
voilà qui lie balle s'appelle bernadette
cet extrait de son nouvel album qui
s'appelle philippe val voilà alors vous
êtes en concert à la cigale de paris le
10 novembre et ensuite tournée dans
toute la france
alors vous dites quand j'étais petit je
crois que j'ai chanté parce que j'étais
gay en fait c'est pour être gai que je
chantais c'est comme respirer c'était
être heureux en chantant we ouais ouais
j'essaie s'intéresser à la chanson conte
votre mère est partie vous aviez quatre
ans à lyon vous est vachement renseignez
vous êtes retrouvé que votre petit fonal
avec la 78 tours exactement 1
c'est là que j'ai commencé à écouter
brassens brel du bonheur c'était du
bonheur ces gens-là sauve des vies
j'ai dix artistes et bien aussi il ya un
troisième produit c'est incroyable qu'à
vous venez pas pour rien c'est un bel
exemple les années charles et ag du
c'est génial c'est vachement bien génial
jorasses effet par cavanna val il ya ça
c'est génial
voilà ça commence la bal tragique à
colombey ça va jusqu'à aujourd'hui
alors on se rend compte que que l'humour
c'est plus comme avant parce que bal
tragique à colombey aujourd'hui vous
êtes vous êtes lyncher quoi vous est
ostracisé pour pour des années non non
je crois pas avant on empile et dancings
sont ignifuges et puis
non non faut pas croire ça on peut
s'exprimer comme on veut 1 il ya des
procès de temps en temps non pas exprimé
comme on veut alors j'avais envie de
vous faire une hardy view mais comme
c'est vous je vous faire une entière
dédiée
[Musique]
alors si tu vas je ne pensais pas à quoi
en ce moment je pense pas que je suis en
train de regarder des conneries à la
télévision dans mon canapé puisque je
suis dedans quand vous regardez le matin
dans la glace vous ne vous dit jamais
quoi je me dis jamais que j'aimerais
être sarkozy en train de me dire que je
veux être président de la république ça
c'est sûr vous n'auriez pas aimé
ressembler à qui quand vous étiez petits
à qui j'aurais pas aimé ressembler pour
l'été petit aux truands qui voulaient
flinguer gary cooper dans le train
sifflera trois fois
qu'est-ce que vous ne quitterez pas pour
le grand amour
la grande amitié quand on vous demande
eu l'autographe vous ne signez jamais
quoi thierry ardisson vous garderiez
quoi en vous si vous aviez une baguette
magique
ben la baguette magique
quel est le péché qui vous tente le
moins l'avarice
ouais je pourriez vous dire de plus
positif sur vos dans une discussion
j'aime bien que les autres aient raison
comme ça j'apprends quelque chose si
votre vie était à refaire vous ne
changeriez à quoi la liberté que j'ai
aujourd'hui dans ma vie et dans mon
boulot qui n'avez vous jamais eu envie
d'épater joe cooker joker parce que
c'est un chanteur génial et je préfère
que celui qui continue m et battait des
records
quelle est la chose que vous ne faites
jamais avant de vous coucher mettre un
pyjama
ah oui non et et le diable dans tout ça
c'est un ami exigeant qu'est ce qui ne
vous énerve pas du tout chez moi votre
cravate qu'est ce que vous n'avez pas
dans le coche la vérité qu'est ce que la
vie nous a toujours pas après la
méfiance
comment n'aimeriez vous pas mourir en
ayant peur de mourir
qui auriez vous aimé ne pas voir ici ce
soir si j'aurais pas aimé voir ici ce
soir je vois les gens qui pensent que
qui avait pas d'avion sur le pentagone
le 11 septembre on n'est pas passé loin
à remarquer d'un risque il faudra
vérifier
faut-il être quelqu'un d'autre que soi
même
bah parfois vous en savez quelque chose
oui à quel signe reconnaissez-vous
infailliblement l'intelligence la
gentillesse bande de cons
existe-t-il une personne que vous
agissiez au point de lui souhaiter de
survivre pinochet trop quelle somme
accepteriez-vous de manger un bol de
caviar et caviar de gauche je mange
gratos
sur lui
j'ai fait mes courses là j'accueille
maintenant guy konopnicki
bien que la pj bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
écrivain essayiste pamphlétaire
journaliste à marianne collaborateurs à
france culture et vous publiez un livre
qui s'appelle prix littéraire la grande
magouille et vous allez vous dire le nom
de l'éditeur jean-claude gaffe si oui
mais c'est parce que l'afrique est édité
chez gap s'est dit alors la première
magouilles ça a été la publication de ce
livre c'est infernal cette histoire
c'est à dire que au départ ça s'appelait
les prix littéraires vont très bien mais
pourquoi plus personne ne les prend au
sérieux
1 ça devait être publié chez belfond
départ c'est ça ce qui est drôle c'est
que c'est lui qui m'a demandé d'écrire
ce livre je l'écris ouais il doit sortir
il devait sortir en septembre 2004 la
couverture était fait la couverture
était fait
un mensuel qui parle de livre m'avait
interviewait je pars en vacances
tranquille j'apprends que mme olive ne
sort pas j'en prends la place de jean
daniel vous voulu proposer un livre sur
les prix littéraires et vous lui
apportez un livre sur la vie littéraire
c'est parce qu'ils voulaient jean daniel
c'est à dire je raconte un truc pied
voilà
avant il y avait des combines entre
maisons d'édition il ya toujours eu des
combines entre maisons d'édition le
problème c'est qu'il y en a deux qui ont
racheté toutes les autres et y en a une
qui achète six sous différentes
étiquettes choisi les livres et dit les
livres décerne les prix va en gros et
tient la moitié des librairies de détail
y'a un truc qui ne va plus puis font des
tas de trucs avec les couvertures
par exemple ils ont acheté pauvert ils
s'en servent pour éditer loana alors
pauvre il avait des défauts pouvait rien
faire de temps en temps des petits
penchant à republier de vieux antisémite
de vieux fasciste et ou de publier et
publiait de la littérature érotique des
choses absolument formidable l'aimé mais
il n'allait pas à la sortie des studios
de télé avec un [ __ ]
dire tiens ça a marché à la télé ça va
marcher dans les librairies
on va inventer la vie de cette fille on
va écrire la vie de cette fille et on va
vendre
je ne crois pas que ça soit exactement
ça la littérature
donc en fait voilà donc d'un côté ya
wendel l'autre côté il ya lagardère vous
n'êtes pas content vous dénoncez ça dans
votre livre on voit bien que là vous
parlez du jour pas des prières ainsi
parce que les de la vie littéraire lipp
riz ils sont dans ce système là c'est à
dire que les cuisines autres maisons
d'édition bon ça ça ça a toujours existé
sauf que maintenant c'est devenu le
label label de qualité sur les poulets
on change de rayon dans le supermarché
on va au rayon livres
alors vous allez acheter votre truc
label rouge est un poulet élevé en plein
air avec lui il a bouffé les mêmes
saloperies mais c'est en plein air et
hop vous allez au rayon librairie j
écris goncourt il ya la belle soeur qui
vient au réveillon c'est pas prévu
qu'est-ce qu'on lui offre tesquet lève
on sait pas il peut arrêter boutines de
temps en temps est-ce qu'elle a eu le
dernier goncourt
ça sert à ça mais c'est très
démocratique ça doit vous regrettez ça
que les livres soient vendus en
supermarché à la cousine qui vient dîner
c'est une façon de démocratiser des bons
livres ça dépend du livre c'est si c'est
le bon livre
et si le label de qualité et fiable 1 il
n'est pas de salle non mais je sais pas
excusez moi de vous dire non mais c'est
pas un scoop de dire que tout ça est
arrangé on le sait depuis longtemps mais
je sais pas c'est marrant parce que
c'est tout le monde c'est oui les prix
littéraires il les distribue soit elle
mais d'ici je te file le renaudot talent
goncourt je te file le prix décembre
non j'ai essayé de regarder non mais
sérieusement j'ai fait le travail j'ai
regardé les scoops qui avait dans votre
bouquin bon ça vous êtes d'accord c'est
pas un scoop sur les petits arrangements
entre amis c'est pas un scoop ça dépend
pour qui
enfin ça dépend pour qui c'est à dire
que il y a les 300 personnes à paris qui
travaille dans l'édition plus quelques
journalistes souvent les mêmes
d'ailleurs besoin
d'abord il ya les dd tout le monde a
plusieurs casquettes
i il annonce la save et puis un cercle
un peu plus élargie qui sait et il ya
même des lecteurs cultivés qui se
foutent des bandes rouges et qui savent
choisir les bouquets 1 1
à des gens attirent on va fourguer des
trucs avec un faux labels
ceux là sont des dizaines de milliers
ceux là sont des lecteurs dont il
commence à tousser
ils commencent à tous c'est à dire tiens
livre inter sa cinquième en dix ans que
le jury change tout c'est pas un scoop
c'est un scoop in est bon alors après ce
qu'on apprend dans va-t-il donc j'ai
regardé ce qu'on apprend dans votre lit
vous dites rouge brésil de rufin ça
s'est pas bien vendu
ça c'est ça j'ai encore improbable par
mailing c'est pas un scoop énorme c'est
non le leur jeu quand il ya une chose
que cette demande est ce que les
lecteurs en en ont retenu rien peut-être
c'est ce que oui ah bon alors que vous
étiez
brigitte bardot a touché 12 millions de
francs d'avaloirs way convient oui oui
mais salle bondée j'accélère
d'intéresser plus nos amis c c'était une
opération rentable pour l'éditeur qu'on
vienne pas nous dire que l'éditeur prend
comme ça des valeurs marchandes pour
pouvoir par ailleurs soutenir ses
auteurs parce que ça c'est pas vrai
c'est à dire que si si un auteur gène
bardot est le mentor de bordeaux de
bardot dans la sphère qui n'était pas
n'importe qui n'importe qui c'est et
françois nourissier ouais donc c'était
le président du goncourt
et là dessus il ya un auteur qui s'amène
et qui dit mais j'en ai marre des beti
fication sur les animaux moi j'ai envie
de défendre les inuits et pas les fuck
moi l'auteur des camps je m'amène chez
grasset avec l'éloge de la fourrure ce
que je t'ai pas ce qu'ils sont en train
de négocier avec brigitte bardot
je tombe mal je tombe mal
je tombe très mal je alors l'auteur
maison qu'est ce qui devient on lui dit
on mais ça va pas non et puis quand même
il ya quelqu'un qui me crache le morceau
dans un couloir et 10 a été fou on est
en train de négocier avec bardot parce
que personne ne lit mélodieux collector
elle était alité et donc quand même on
est encore libre j'ai traversé la rue
chalet au seul essai par le dos mais
voilà alors il ya ça avant après ou
parler de ce qu'on appelle les noms
livre alors vous dites que simone
signoret écrivait mieux que benjamin
castaldi oui elle est surtout plus de
choses à raconter parce qu'elle était
simone signoret que
casque d'or on le regardera encore dans
50 ans et je pense que les idées aussi
et je pense que je pense que les vidéos
des émissions de castaldi elles sont
déjà plus regardable bien les hommes
politiques
vous n'avez pas de [ __ ] dimanche il y
avait quelque chose à dire il écrivait
quelques semaines avait un porte avions
il a eu trois rivaux lionel dutemple
[Applaudissements]
maintenant tu as vu leurs crimes donc
vous êtes content de votre bouquin
finalement mais dans l'ensemble bruit
très à l'étroit dans son oui c'est à
dire je crois qu'il faut un peu dire les
choses qu'il faut aussi invité cet
honorable profession à à réfléchir un
peu je crois que les livres auraient
besoin d'une autre autorité indépendante
qui ne dépendent pas des maisons
d'édition qui donne de vrais label qui
choisissent vraiment des livres qui
conseille les lecteurs pour ça il
faudrait renouveler ces jurys en
permanence fsb d'essayer à beigbeder a
essayé au prix de flore de dire il faut
que les jurés change tous les ans bon
bah y est pas arrivé je peux dire que
les mômes de 30 ans à ce qu'ils
associent conques les vieux de 65 mm
même quand ils ont trente ans les jurés
littéraire ils veulent pas bouger big
ennemis qui vous révéler dans votre
livre qu'il ya 1150 prix dit que la
france
je vous propose ce soir d'en créer un
mille cent cinquante et unième ne prit
conapp 2004 et en faire une interview
prix conapp 2004
alors le bouquin qui vous a filé des
boutons alors ça c'est non c'est
christine angot parce qu'alors ça il y
en a il y en a un par an c'est toujours
aussi mal écrit c'est toujours aussi
glauque
c'est toujours des histoires sans
intérêt et en plus il ya une pièce de la
maison que l'on retrouve dans tous les
livres c'est les toilettes avec une
description de la cuvette propre salle
alors le lecteur est pas dépaysés parce
qu'en général quand il y christine angot
c'est qu'il est assis dessus sur
lesquels va être quelque cent des
votants
le bouquin qui vous a endormi à loubieng
qui m'a endormi c est pourtant qu'est ce
que j'aime les polars qu'est ce que
j'aime les trucs à énigmes j'écris les
polars aussi là je suis colère tout
court et alors le code vinci pendant ces
inédits
l'énigme c'est que ça soit un million
d'exemplaires c'est que cet été sur la
plage je vois les gens le quelqu'un est
en train de lire en italien il y en a un
autre qui dit en allemand bunte lisant
français ce truc marche c'est formidable
hi hi hi - non non je n'accroche pas
bien je pense j'accroche pas mais ça
arrive ça arrive
le bouquin qui méritait pas de trouver
un éditeur
c'est le san antonio écrit par le fils
de frédéric dard alors c'est le
troisième du genre versailles a vraiment
ras le cul nemaska fils de mme
apparemment si j'aime bien les fils doit
par exemple bien mais mais mais il fait
de la musique la littérature tient et le
fils frédéric dard le fils frédéric dard
n'est que le fils de frédéric dard il
pourrait avoir un talent formidable
c'est pas le cas
nebout cas avec le meilleur [ __ ] alors
je ne suis pas une balance
je ne suis pas une balance mais il ya
juste des trucs formidables par exemple
je pense à cannes on par exemple
chrétiens par exemple je pense que moi
et je pense que nicolas sarkozy est un
type formidable
il a eu le temps d'écrire une biographie
de georges mandel qui était un très
grand homme politique qui lui écrivait
lui-même
ça c'est quand même vachement bien le
bouquin qui vous a donné envie de tuer à
le bouquin qui m'a donné envie de tuer
ça c'est ça c'est catherine allégret
place elle l'a fait elle même et on ne
vient pas raconter ça d annie après sa
mort alors après il ya des trucs c'est
vrai que c'est dur d'avoir casque d'or
pour maman et et servir le café à
navarro c'est vrai que bon décale ans
des familles qu'est ce que vous voulez
qui mérite son succès alors soit que
c'est jean paul dubois très joli livre
city risque pas à voir le prix parce que
les patchs et de bon éditeur mais mais
mais qui vont assez bien et il mérite
son succès sinon il ya le guignol
magistrats aussi qui est pas mal qui est
pas mal
le bouquin qui a trop de pages alors
bien qu'il ya trop de pages c'est celui
de daniel rondeau c'est dommage parce
que ça part bien on se dira voilà un
romancier qui va nous remettre un peu
des personnages dans la grande histoire
qu'on me faisait les repentis du 19e
siècle
j'adore ça sauf que à un moment où nous
raconte la grande histoire sans ces
personnages qui ne sont plus que des
spectateurs nous raconte des trucs qu'on
sait déjà avec des personnages qu'on
peut avec des personnages qu'on connaît
c'est un peu dommage il dit qu'il a mis
dix ans à le faire voler dietrich un peu
pro fabre je crois pas il a plus de
talent que ça daniel rondeau il n'a pas
mis dix ans à le faire mais bon et il a
mis trop de trucs et c'est dommage il
aurait resserrer un peu ça faisait un
bout revend le bouquin qui mériterait le
goncourt 2004 jeu l'auteur s'appelle
presque goncourt il s'appelle serge
joncour et publie un roman qui s'appelle
l' idole c'est chez flammarion se
rendant qui s'appelle lidl
c'est un type et réveille le matin il y
célèbre comme il est célèbre il va
passer à la télé et comme il va passer à
la télé il va faire un bouquin du moins
on va lui faire un bouquin ça c'est
absolument formidable parce que c'est ce
système dans lequel on est en plus c'est
d'une drôlerie se dire que sous ce type
et alphonse allais ya tristan daraya
breton il ya ya le grand humour noir
règles caustique et c'est vraiment un
roman on rigole à chaque page mais
quelqu'un qui va sans doute gagner le
goncourt 2004
grasset fait le forcing bon ils ont ils
en ont besoin d'un ils ont besoin d'un
ils ont concédé l'année dernière ils
sont ils sont battus en recul
ils ont perdu un juré le avoir le
goncourt en 2004 abbas a le le l'europe
atteint réponse que les les les jurés
iron man j'ai géré ou en 8 heures à
grenade où les gens connaissent pas ce
parti que l'appliquer j'accueille
maintenant david d'état
comment ça va guéthary
il reconnaît que ahmed ouais pourquoi
pas pourquoi je vais te dire pourquoi
pas 10 ans j'ai galéré pour rentrer en
boîte de nuit le sol la seule boîte de
nuit où je rentre assez tôt badouche ces
voix là bas mais comment va 4,6 des cas
mais ça va bien
commande à tim elvis tim elvis va très
bien il a quand même appelé son fils
thibault
en fait on l'appelait on l'appelle elvis
alors je me suis même maxime c'est un
peu en fait tu arrivé je suis arrivé à
la mairie
ouais on avait décidé elvis et puis au
dernier moment je me suis dit que quand
même si vous voulez être banquier ou
effectivement la prof de maths ou avocat
ça ne fait pas très sérieux de lui
donner le choix entre elvis s'il voulait
être artiste comme nous ou si vous
voulez faire un métier peut-être un peu
plus sérieux team srt boueux par rapport
à moi déjà c'est sérieux c'est plus
sérieux qu'elle vise
comment mal en pire guetta bon y'a pas
d'empiré guetta tu sois ici il ya quand
même le temps jahia le pink latina nous
l'avons vendu à et aujourd'hui on
s'occupe surtout cathy d'ailleurs
puisque moi je fais plutôt de la musique
en ce moment
du de la suite oui du pink paradise qui
est un club de strip tease qui marche
très très bien qui était le premier en
france et c'est devenu un classique
maintenant voilà en fait à des boîtes à
cucq moi c'est pareil oui y'a du cul
mais il n'ya pas que ça c'est comme la
tv mais voilà il ya la musique donc
puisque maintenant musique c'est vrai
dire surtout la nuit tu as fait une
entrée remarquée alors je voudrais te
remercie au passage parce que j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure dans le danton
sampler là le remis ce que j'ai fait de
david bowie toutes les semaines mais
alors je ne sais si je suis vraiment
content j'adore c'est très plaisir
il a fait un remix de heroes de bowie
qui est magnifique l'a fait et ensuite
ils avaient peur que bowie soit pas
d'accord pour ça sorte et bowie a été
d'accord grâce à dieu c'est génial
[Musique]
ça toutes les semaines je le mets jeu
l'adorent maintenant il ya le troisième
album qui s'appelle guetta blaster voilà
tu as compris la vanne l'un des grands
formats mais cela n'est qu'un mec un peu
stricte on se comprend c'est marrant
hein
voilà j'aime la musique et qui aiment la
musique est alors le morceau en promo 10
on s'appelle stay voilà
[Musique]
voilà c'était ils seraient deux guetta
blaster donc le nouveau cd dois dire qu
on est disque d'or
déjà avec l'album est donc je suis assez
content voilà c'est une bonne nous tous
qui fait ça marche je suis ça m'énerve
ouais alors est-ce que tu connais
orlando au toit oui on travaille pas
ensemble mais je la connais
il était souvent à la table à côté de
lui tu va regarder ta caméra
c'est le cas de rouge d'accord si tu
regardes et tu as caméras chez lui à le
rouge et tu vas dire magnéto serge
magnéto serge bien
m
[Musique]
c
pour
qu'est-ce que vous avez mal c'est vrai
il est en train de rappeler un truc
c'est vraiment génial c'est il ya trois
quatre ans où ben autour d'un verre en
discuter et puis je disais que tu sais
j'ai repris la musique mais comme ça on
a une conversation amicale et à bon
j'espère c'est un marché juteux si je
fais vraiment ça pour m'amuser je pense
pas du tout que ça marchera mais en tout
cas je m'éclate je vais au studio toutes
les semaines il s'est un peu marcher ça
tombe bien moi je viens juste
d'apprendre que des auteurs des guignols
drogba depuis des années boucherie david
pourquoi tu as fait des jo qui n'avait
pas le physique pour être poète videurs
en fait je suis arrivé je suis arrivé
vraiment dans la nuit par la musique moi
je j'ai commencé mon premier job de djs
et quand j'avais 17 ans et j'ai jamais
fréquenté les clubs pour draguer ou pour
sortir avec des copains ou ou ni même
vraiment pour danser d'ailleurs j'ai
toujours je suis toujours là pour mixer
parce que depuis que j'ai 14 ans
j'achète des disques et à part la drogue
tu prends quoi pour tenir ce rythme
tout à l'heure super il en reste il
commence à y tape tout à l'heure au
maquillage ma faim
une petite erreur de parcours j'avais
plein de poudre blanche en bas d'une et
j aimerais non non c'est comment c'est
quoi ton secret là mais justement c'est
pas de drogue
l'amour un thé pas de drogue c'est l'ami
l'amour ouais tu n'as jamais vu la
lumière du jour cathy paraît c'est vrai
tu as toute sa vie dans les bois tu vas
ou quand tu veux t'amuser
en ce moment je vais en angleterre tous
les week-end et je m'éclate
voilà je veux bien croire et david
guetta et je le dis et je sais que ça va
vous coûter très cher demain dans le
quartier mais il est beaucoup plus
simple de grandes que 90% des rappeurs
cjb j'assume mais il lui revient à bondy
je crois qu'on va rester là dessus parce
que ça c'est quand même un très beau
compliment
[Musique]
tél
et pour ce blind test spécial usa
j'appelle crise de muter fonctionnement
[Musique]
alors vous connaissez le principe un ya
deux équipes dans un premier temps
l'équipe de karine ferri contre l'équipe
de bruno gaccio et je veux évidemment
les interprètes tué près crise je suis
l'interprète joue
david guetta
g
j'ai jamais
c
sacré que moi il est riche
bon alors donc le point va à l'équipe de
karine veille puis oui 0 nouveaux robots
[Applaudissements]
dc
[Musique]
bravo donc le point avec l'équipe de
bruno gaccio ça fait un partout
bien bien bien c'est bien les cuivres
dans cette chanson un film basic
continue crise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est beau
oh
hélas
pour moi parce que c'est trop facile
ça fait deux points pour l'équipe de
karine bravo ma petite karine war liesse
et dire non tu l'as dit avance
tu arrivé
serge petit et bleu
bon bah
et vous
ah ben c'est comme ça peut arriver à toi
partenaires je réalise des guignols ou
toi le réalisateur des guignols c'est
vrai on continue crise
la paix
sophie noël
bravo à web histoire bravo alors ça fait
2 pour l'équipe de gaston iv pour
l'équipe de karine on continue crise
[Musique]
tf6
avant j'étais là
comment
je
[Musique]
5 pour karine 2 pour gaccio en continu
crise
[Musique]
de boer
thomson top flop du soufflage il a vu le
bonhomme le tenir à 10 de seconde après
j'ai dit à l'oreille
il a dit allez nana na na pas parce
qu'on a donné des cours de céder mais il
m'a dit vas-y vas-y
regarde moi moi
une crise
m
il était
[Musique]
oui catherine envoie guetta qui disent
que guetta c'est à moi qui doit répondre
olala c'est pas la gueule et je suis
désolé carton jaune pour guetta est ici
a eu soufflage donc le point bas quand
même là je sais je sais c'est injuste
mais la vie elle même est injuste voilà
ça fait 6 points pour ma chérie pour
karine et eu le mérite bien
comme quoi je trouve ça très petit je
trouve ça extrêmement petit comme quoi
les compétitions qui semblent les plus
honnêtes ne sont jamais c'est ça qu'il
faut dénoncer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je viens aussi de découvrir que les
auteurs des guignols écoutent de la
musique c'est joli ça c'est qui ça
léon
mais là le point contre parme bon
continue crise
en
à
tant mailing je le crois pas c'est 7
points pour karine et trois points pour
gassion aussi alors handicap est un
remontable après la même pas depuis sept
huit ans après alors vas-y crise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
phrase de ce soir
[Musique]
hubert henno
à
j'ai gardé rancune
mik
je vais
[Musique]
hu
blanc avait justement monde
sur un mois
et puis de toute façon les gommes que tu
le dit ou pas comme le point été marqué
par quelqu'un de ton côté le point bas
chez vous s'est expliqué jeudi lors des
quarts avec des jeux qu'est ce qu'il me
dit à moi c'est pas beau oui mais je
m'en fous dit lui c'est beau c'est sûr
pire c'était beau oui bah oui
moi
[Musique]
ma région
bah dis donc
[Musique]
non
ina
oui
au jeu
si la couenne arrête là tarbes dans la
bande
pendant la guerre il est monté
non
c'est manu marche
[Musique]
jemâa
g
diawara non validées avant m'attendais
catherine barma à ce niveau là à ce
niveau là il n'ya que barmaki par baril
à ottawa a bien vu que je l'avais dit
avant katrina dit ahmed hamidi bravo
voilà c'est un point qui va de l'autre
côté alors mais oui d'accord j'ai
compris ce système ça va j'ai compris
mes rides mais à l'issue du par équipe
et si oui j'appelle jusqu'à tessier bien
certains soirs on attelle tissier pour
savoir qu'il ya lieu donc bruno gaccio 5
points karine cette brave au carré à
l'annoncé chez rien dans sa gamme un
terrien magnifique sac de points que
nous pourrions partager avec plein de
gens à être heureux tous les deux ans
il a dit au début d'émission ça fait 15
ans qu'il avait dit au début je prédis
pas tiré non tu as dis pas fait d'amour
voilà
non mais il ya juste une en arabe c'est
tout cherchez bien allons-y
en regardant en face au chacun pour sa
gueule c'est horrible y a plus d'équipé
a plus d'amis vive le liberia puis de
solidarité c'est alain madelin qui a
pris le pouvoir effectivement crise
basique
[Musique]
c'est hyper facile
stevie wonder world un barreau george
benson et voyage de m
b
[Musique]
aaron
donc cpf qui marque le premier chacun
pour sa gueule on passe deuxième c'est
le super banco
[Musique]
les chanteurs et chanteuses et
maintenant aller
[Musique]
au maroc un dîner
[Applaudissements]
c
bon karine et maintenant on arrive au
méga bon côté c'est à dire que la
personne qui va trouver sera le roi ou
la reine de la soirée c'est assez
compliqué mais nous regarde
allez vous jouer ensemble tu es prêt tu
peux trouver en plus vous êtes prêt
crise
[Musique]
et
et je
[Musique]
je dois
m
et voilà
[Musique]
c'est par david guetta extrait de ce
nouvel album ghettoblaster tu as quand
tu gagnes tout droit m
[Musique]
voilà c'était sûrement dans ta avec
bruno gaccio lionel dutemple ahmed
hamidi pour le planter l'aîné des
guignols jean-pierre ça peut tout faire
pascal sevran pascal se
pour l'album entraîner
marina foïs époque merci l'histoire de
france 2 avant maintenant des robins des
bois chez canal+ éditions albin michel
éric leurent la face cachée du 11
septembre publié chez plon
le sergent chef adam sur les traces
d'al qaïda publié chez albin édition
karim fait rilsan choses interdites aux
plus de 30 ans tous les mercredis à
partir du 27 octobre à 17h10 sur feu de
télé voilà je recopiais l'album
s'appellera obame charles et le dvd live
s'appelle the best of joe cocker
minimale bons baisers de ben laden et
cherche une édition les années charlie
1969 à 2004
aïe franchois qu'elana chez lui que et
l'album is back avec le single
bernadette philippe val sera le 10
novembre à la cigale de paris bercy dit
que l'appli qui prit vite et à la grande
magouille chez jean-claude et du joueur
david guetta l'album s'appelle david
guetta blaster le single s'appelle style
est en tournée dans le monde entier le
dj du blind test merci s'appelle chris
de multifunkshun voilà si on va entendre
un de ses morceaux
pendant le générique de pain c'était
tout le monde à aller semaine prochaine
en remercie
[Musique]
oui
tous
vous
[Musique]
oh
m
senna
là
mata
fascinant
[Musique]
c'est
m